[Musique]
oh
bonsoir mesdames et messieurs bon
dimanche soir bienvenue à ce premier
grand rendez vous électoral
ce soir ce n'est pas le débat que nous
vous présenterons le 22 septembre
ce soir ce sont des entrevues en direct
les cinq chefs des principaux partis
viendront à tour de rôle répondre à nos
questions céline bonsoir anne marie
bonsoir sa batterie remet sol oui on
l'avait fait pour le fédéral est là bas
le public avait beaucoup apprécié donc
oui on remet sort très heureuse d'être
ici avec vous deux et pour nous c'est un
peu le lancement de cette campagne
électorale oui beaucoup de gens je crois
que ce sera lente parce qu'en même temps
c'est un privilège de recevoir les cinq
chefs en 2h 2h pour convaincre li
millions d'électeurs alors ils sont les
bienvenus on les atteint on est prêt les
chefs d'ailleurs sont arrivés à radio
canada il ya quelques minutes vous allez
voir les images l'ordre a été déterminée
selon leur nombre de députés élus donc
premier invité le chef de la caq
françois legault
on va faire des grands changements venez
faire dans l'homme on va donner
nos engagements
[Musique]
on s'est engagé à interdire le port de
signes religieux pour les employés de
l'état en position d'autorité
on va respecter nos engagements
ce tunnel québec lévis c'est un projet
qui est nécessaire pour québec pour les
vies et pour tout l'est du québec
[Musique]
compter de samedi qui vient pour quatre
semaines on va avoir un couvre-feu au
québec la priorité actuellement c'est
pour trouver des coupables c'est de
s'occuper des aînés si on fait rien à
long terme parce que ça prendra 25 50 60
ans il ya un risque effectivement que le
québec surtout dans même situation que
les autres provinces canadiennes que la
louisiane on veut céder on va remettre
de l'argent dans votre portefeuille pour
recouvrer cette inflation moi je veux
des résultats au coeur quand je vais me
présenter devant les électeurs en 2022
je veux des résultats
[Musique]
monsieur legault bonsoir bonsoir et vous
trois mois soit vous allez bien problème
merci d'avoir accepté l'invitation on va
à tous les chefs posé une première
question sur ce climat qu'on a des noms
aussi cette semaine le climat
d'agressivité ces menaces de mort même
pauline marois s'il y a dix ans jour
pour jour donc au métropolis cet
attentat politique
actuellement ce que vous vous attribuez
ce climat ou mesures sanitaires cette
grogne mesures sanitaires
d'abord ce qui est arrivé est madame
marois c'est différent de ce qu'on vit
actuellement moi j'ai été premier
ministre depuis quatre ans je me suis
pas senti en danger depuis quatre ans je
pense la sûreté du cas du québec fait un
excellent travail maintenant que
plusieurs raisons je pense pourquoi il
ya de la violence il ya d'abord les
médias sociaux c'est très dur sur les
médias sociaux c'est pas nouveau là je
vais de temps en temps voir ces cris ces
violents bon est ce qu'il ya un lien à
faire avec les mesures center peut-être
en partie pour ça que j'ai lancé un
appel je le fais encore ce soir c'est
important que tous les québécois fassent
attention soit pauvre violents dans
leurs propos
l'argent maintenant monsieur legault on
en a beaucoup parlé d'argent aussi cette
semaine vous vous promettez 8 milliards
de baisses d'impôts en quatre ans or on
attend encore des citoyens attendent
jusqu'à 25 heures aux urgences on remet
deux à quatre personnes dans les jambes
de sécheresse elle dit on voulait plus
faire ça ce qu'on devrait pas éteindre
ces feux lors à vendin ses impôts faut
faire les deux parce qu'actuellement
nous faut comprendre que ya beaucoup de
québécois qui souffrent pensons par
exemple aux personnes âgées qui ont des
pensions quand ils vont l'épicerie sa
demande de 6 7% quand ils vont acheter
de l'essence y arrive pas donc faut les
aider de façon ponctuelle pour ça qu'on
dit dès 2022 pour les personnes de 50
ans et plus il va y avoir un montant de
2000 $ jusqu'à 2000 $ par année ensuite
il y aura un autre montant non récurrent
décembre en 400 et 500 ch eck mais les
baisses
régler les urgences puis baisse des
impôts bon c'est d'abord il ya des
chèques décembre puis pour les aînés
ensuite des baisses d'impôts à partir de
glaner prochain en 2023 c'est important
parce que on a un écart de richesse au
québec avec l'ontario on a des impôts
des taux d'impôts qui sont beaucoup plus
élevés que notre que celui de nos
voisins
je pense qu'il faut donner un peu d'air
aux contribuables et je pense qu'on est
capable de le faire en même temps qu'on
finance bien la santé l'éducation
nos services de base monsieur jego
c'était une de vos principales promesses
en 2018 fournir un médecin de famille à
chaque québécois à tous les québécois là
il ya huit cent mille personnes qui sont
sur la liste d'attenté du double d'il ya
quatre ans et maintenant vous promettez
l'accès à un professionnel de la santé
est ce que donc vous jugez que c'est
impossible de donner un médecin à tout
le monde c'est terminé d'abord faut
rétablir les faits quand on est arrivé
le 1er octobre 2018 il y avait six
points 4 millions de québécois qui avait
un médecin de famille aujourd'hui en
16.7 millions donc vous parler de succès
inscrit sur la liste en 2018 il
s'inscrivait même pas sur la liste parce
qu'il était convaincu qui en aurait pas
mais aujourd'hui il ya trois cent mille
québécois de plus qu'un médecin de
famille qui ont un engagement du
syndicat des médecins de famille
d'augmenter sa 500 milles d'ici le 30
avril aura tenu un stand qui n'auront
pas exerce
d'abord il faut se dire qu'on est une
pandémie je pense tous les québécois qui
nous écoutent comprennent que d'abord
fait d'être déchiré l'entente des
libéraux parce qu'il ya les libéraux
avaient signé une entente avec les
médecins de famille jusqu'en 2023
donc fallu déchirer leur temps puis
constanta du l'été passé le 4 la part
des mythes à moins fort
mais il faut que les québécois aient
tous accès à un groupe de médecine de
famille ça soit infirmière ou un médecin
cas qui en ont besoin quand même pas la
même chose quel médecin de famille en
termes de prise en charge mais monsieur
legault
parce que là vous prenez un argument d
opposition là quand ils vont avoir
besoin d'un médecin ils vont avoir accès
à un médecin quand ils ont besoin
d'infirmières vont avoir accès à une
infirmière mais pour les médecins à un
médecin de famille pour chaque québécois
sauce vous vous renoncer à cette promo
du tout ce qu'on dit c'est tous les
québécois vont avoir accès un groupe de
médecine de famille quand ils vont avoir
besoin il va avoir un portail votre
santé vont pouvoir les prendre rendez
vous puis la garantie qu'on va leur
donner scandale 36 heures ils vont être
capables de voir un médecin ou une
infirmière selon leurs besoins monsieur
legault à 2018 c'était hier vous étiez
prêt à mettre votre siège en jeu pour
les maternelles quatre ans sa promesse
là étaient remplis en partie seulement
1600 cela sur les 5000 promise ans en
2018 ce soir maintenant pour quels
enjeux êtes vous prêt à mettre votre
siège en jeu bondé prochaine c'est
d'abord en 2018 ce qu'on a dit ce comté
peau augmente on a triplé le nombre de
maternelle 4 ans puis pour moi ça reste
la priorité de lutter contre le
décrochage puis pour le faire faut agir
tôt donc même à 24,1 avec lionel carmant
on a mis en place des évaluations dès
lors de deux ans le les québécois ont le
choix et en a qui préfèrent aller dans
une garderie qui est ouvert 12 mois par
année il y en a d'autres qui est mieux
d'aller dans une maternelle 4 1 qui
pouvait regretter mais où il ya des
orthophonistes des orthopédagogues ont
augmenté de 2000 le nombre d'autos
fournisse édes orthopédagogue et on a
amélioré de maillots la pandémie qui est
fait les écoles ont été fermées donc ce
rapport facilité mais c'est comme ça
partout dans le monde mais pour moi cet
accord essentiel que tous les enfants
tout le 25 % d'enfants qui ont des
difficultés d'apprentissage qui accès
s'ils le souhaitent à une maternelle 4
ans c'est comme ça beaucoup d'endroits
dans le monde d'ailleurs monsieur
legault le français ont beaucoup ont
sursauté avec les derniers chiffres de
statistique canada vous avez légiférer
mais voyant les derniers chiffres est-ce
que vous avez l'intention de légiférer à
nouveau de réglementer à nouveau par
exemple la question des cégeps que vous
aviez tu as assisté près revenir dans le
prochain mandat en disant on va
interdire aux francophones et aux
allophones tel au cégep anglophone dont
la clé si on veut arrêter puis on
veulent arrêter le déclin du français
c'est l'immigration
on limite le nombre d'immigrants chaque
année à 50 milles il ya une partie qui
est choisi par québec une partie qui est
choisi par ottawa dans la partie qui est
choisi par québec
gouvernement libéral péquiste
choisissait seulement 50% qui parle des
français nous on est rendu à 80 % qui
parlent français et l'on demande à
ottawa d'avoir aussi notre mot à dire
dans sélection le succès choisi par
ottawa c'est là la clé c'est
l'immigration willow 3 qui vous dit non
d'ailleurs là-dessus encore winum
l'impression que j'ai pas de rapport de
force beaucoup là dessus on a obtenu
services de garde ont obtenu des
milliards mais pour lui la raison mais
l'immigration
je pense que il fois des chercheurs
rapport de force je pense qu'il ya une
majorité de québécois qui serait
d'accord avec ça beaucoup plus d'accord
d'ailleurs que fin un référendum sur la
souveraineté donc moi j'y crois qu'on va
aller chercher c'est pour avoir monsieur
legault y est c'est l'immigration la clé
vous vous voulez plafonné à 50 milles au
canada savez-vous condé ils veulent
accueillir ses 450 mais les migrants
2023 repos dans dix ans ça prend pas un
doctorat en mathématiques
la proportion du québec va baisser comme
peau de chagrin canada c'est une
plafonné à 50 me allez vous être
l'artisan du déclin du québec au canada
pas du tout bon d'abord faut comprendre
qu'il ya cinquante mille le québec c'est
un des états d'un monde qui reçoit
toutes proportions gardées le petit en
omettant les menottes plus qu aux etats
unis plus qu'en france de fédérale
c'est son choix mais nous ce qu'on va
vouloir se protéger le nombre de députés
fédéraux qui viennent du québec donc le
poids du québec à ottawa
c'est important de le protéger c'est
important aussi de respecter les champs
de compétence donc c'est là dessus qu'on
déborde actuellement vous êtes le nombre
de députés vont être protégé mais en
termes de proportion de pourcentage vous
voyez vous constatez que le québec va
baisser par rapport à la population
canadienne ben écoutez le québec l'a
surtout avec le français
on est huit millions dans un océan 300
millions d'anglophones notre capacité
d'intégration
pour moi un limité à 50 milles donc faut
quand même si on veut protéger le
français
limiter l'augmentation du nombre
d'immigrants pour moi c'est non
négociable de protéger le français donc
les entreprises dont plusieurs en hautes
technologies qui vous supplie presque à
genoux en âmes sur le go
70 euros - il faut qu'il y en ait plus
qui est à bien les franciser pourquoi
peut pas en prendre plus puissants
occupé mieux comme j'ai bien dit les
franciser est bon d'abord on a mis en
place des incitatifs important pour ceux
qui étudient en éducation en santé en
service de garde mais aussi en
technologies de l'information par n'est
générée donc des gros incitatifs on a
mis trois milliards de dollars 17 71 des
québécois aussi qu'ils vont changer
d'emploi
prenez par exemple le secteur du
commerce de détail mais il va avoir
moins d'emplois pour qualifier une
partie de ces gens là vers les
technologies d'information parce que
c'est laurent trop ça se débloque ces
cinquante mille vous êtes 50000
puisqu'ils étaient bien là c'est la
richesse par habitant sipa la richesse
totale ne sont pas les choses total
c'est la chine mais il ya des pays comme
la suisse les pays scandinaves qui sont
petits mais très riche et donc ce qu'on
vise c'est que les québécois et des
meilleurs emplois
traitement il ya des augmentations de
salaires très importante qui se donnent
au québec c'est bon les travailleurs
voulu le fameux six mois pour apprendre
le français vous le voyez vous le
constatez c'est un irritant les groupes
qui travaillent les nouveaux arrivants
dise ce qu'on peut ouvrir un pipi
l'épreuve du rock et un an est ce que
vous y tenez mordicus à ce six mois
avant que l'état communique uniquement
français avec les nouveaux arrivants
étaient la plupart des pays d'un monde
sous arrivent en italie il arrive en
allemagne on vous envoie des documents
dans la langue du pays nous il ya une
langue officielle au québec c'est le
français donc non enfin exception pour
six mois après six mois les gens devront
et puis va avoir des services portuaires
qui veulent le traduire mais c'est déjà
beaucoup qu'on donne les documents dans
leur âme pendant six mois à peu près
partout dans le monde dès la journée 1
ils reçoivent les documents d'al alam de
l'état c'est ce qu'on va faire très bien
monsieur legault merci c'est le gros
l'environnement oui
lâchez moi avec les jeux s est ce que
c'est votre le titre de votre nouveau
plan vert c'est ce qu'a dit votre
candidat dans les vies bernard
drainville en défendant le troisième
vient il faut remettre la déclaration
dans son contexte j'étais juste à côté
de lui on lui a dit mais comment vous
pouvez pour l'environnement puis pour le
troisième signé bonnes questions et vous
mieux besoin d'un troisième lien québec
quand on regarde le nombre d'autos qui
même pour le transport en commun faut
qu'il ya eu lié centre-ville à
centre-ville ancli vie et québec donc il
y aura effectivement du transport
collectif dans le tunnel québec lévis 2
voies sur 4 qui aura éventuellement
aussi des autos électriques c'est la
bernardie lâchez-moi que les gs on a
besoin d'un troisième lien québec la
question qui reste veux-t-on défigurer
les leurs les uns ou si on veut tout net
c'est la question qui
met des voitures électriques ou pas ça
va être la même congestion parce que ça
va être des voitures quand même et un
projet autoroutier comme le troisième
bien monsieur le groupe ça va augmenter
le nombre de voitures n'ont actuellement
de deux ponts le pont pierre laporte
puis le pont de québec je sais pas qui
cite des lots mecs ont un côté de l'ocs
sont congestionnés son âge eu un tunnel
québec lévis pour lui d'avoir d'heuliez
durant trois liés donc il y aura moins
de congestion incluant le transport
collectif
je pense ça va être beaucoup plus
populaire le transport collectif des
centre-ville à centre-ville andy ne que
d'aller faire le tour par les deux ponts
en prenant 1 30 noeuds mais ya pas une
étude sérieuse qui démontre la nécessité
ne soit vous de vous en avez des études
mais pourquoi voulez vous les dévoiler
petite folle et met à jour les études
parce que avec la pandémie le
télétravail va changer ces données là
donc on est en train de l'est met à jo
mais pour moi une évidence que besoin
d'un troisième niveau pas pourquoi des
gens à montréal aurait plus de ponts que
les gens à québec compte tenu du nombre
de l'essonne c'est ce que soutient quand
on tient compte de la population puis
des projections des prochaines années on
a besoin d'un troisième lieu à québec
faut que les gens montréal arrête de
regarder de haut les gens québec puis de
lévis est ce que ça veut dire que vous
pensez qu'il faut maintenir donc le
nombre de l'automobile est ce que il est
patent d'imposer certaines restrictions
aux gens parce que je faire la
transition vers un environnement plus
plus un ça va ça va prendre des
sacrifices est ce que vous allez imposé
par exemple une taxe comme le fait
québec solidaire sur les plus gros vie
qu on était un des premiers
gouvernements au monde le gouvernement
du québec à dire à partir de 2035 ça
sera défendue devant des véhicules d'un
sens on est au même niveau que la
californie donc on est parmi les étoles
et plus progressistes mais janvier sur
le troisième ligne si on veut faire la
promotion du transport collectif en
québec lévis faut qu'il y ait de
centre-ville à centre-ville mais tous
les experts disent qu'il faut réduire le
nombre de voitures monsieur donc est ce
que vous pourriez imposé par exemple une
taxe sur les gros véhicules sont les
gros véhicules qui sont de plus en plus
nombreux sont nos routes ce qu'on vit
actuellement on up au 56 milliards de
projets de transports collectifs faut
d'abord qu'ils soient en place avant de
commencer à imposer des choses en
attendant malheureusement les gens
doivent continuer à
circuler en voiture mais encore là on a
des incitatifs qui sont parmi les plus
élevés au monde pour acheter des autos
électriques le problème ce qui est un
délai de livraison avec ces français
dans l'alimentation étaient plus proches
6 à 6 au lieu de 1035 vous interdisait
les voitures à essence avant les gros
sous terre où l'on verrait livres
disponibles des autos électriques les
constructeurs là il ya eu comme un prix
des chaînes d'approvisionnement avec la
guerre en ukraine avec tout ce qu'on a
vécu actuellement les gens qui bougent
en connaît qui veulent acheter une auto
électrique
il y en as poneys et construire les
envoie là où la réglementation est plus
strict mais on est faux on est la preuve
s'il ne juge de tout lectrique ça c'est
une zone qui est en avant de la parade
oublions pas qu en amérique du nord
c'est québec que les plus beaux grs par
habitant on y lisent salek la californie
avoir une bourse du carbone donc on
n'est pas mis sur soixante et un ans et
provinces le québec donc arrêtons de
tony sur le québec on est premiers
fonderie horne de rouyn noranda monsieur
legault veut directeur de la santé
publique trt que cinq ans c'est trop
long pour atteindre la norme de
quinzaine de grammes par mètre cube
d'arsenic dans l'air avec les risques
pour la santé des gens est ce que vous
vous trouvez ça acceptable 50 et la
parole est maintenant aux indes rouyn
noranda
2200 emplois payants à rouyn noranda
le directeur de la santé publique dit
fodor éventuellement baisser à 5
nanogrammes les technologies existent
pas actuellement il y aura des
décontaminations on va consulter dans
les prochaines semaines légende rouyn
noranda c'est eux qui vont décider pas
les jeunes montréal les gens de roue
l'avant du docteur boileau dit le délai
de cinq ans ce n'est pas ce que nous
souhaitons ce que nous souhaitons voir
s'il faut que la norme sécuritaire la
case nano grammes soit instauré la laci
mondiale comme il faut la déclaration du
dr lô ski di c
c'est pas ce qu'on souhaite on
souhaiterait aller à 5 nanogrammes c'est
ce qui dit on est d'accord on dit la
même chose que le docteur boileau
maintenant c'est aux gens de rouyn
noranda a décidé
mais c'est le goût oui
un autre chapitre oui celui est assez
long celui là selon des élus des listes
d'attentes là où ça fait mal au sacre
dans plusieurs secteurs elle s'allonge
commençons par les listes d'attenté en
chirurgie 159,4 bull québécois 21000 de
plus de l'année dernière que l'année
dernière vous savez que ces gens-là
qu'attendent ils sauvent sont angoissés
ils veulent une solution ils veulent
savoir quand ils vont être opérés quand
ils vont reprendre leurs activités alors
comment venir à bout bon d'abord je
parle avec les premiers ministres et aux
provinces incluant deux fois de
l'ontario ces deux mêmes problèmes
partout pourquoi parce que pendant la
pandémie pour être capable de traiter
les gens de la cave il a fallu retarder
de géorgie on peut pas inventer des
infirmières ça prend trois ans donc ce
quelqu'un à une baguette magique qui
viennent nous dit actuellement le
meilleur gestionnaire avec christian
dubé puis on est entré d'aménager au rac
fois le mieux possible avec les
ressources qu'on ne les lis était déjà
longue avant la pandémie en parlant des
urgences maintenant fait semaines avant
même un message des hôpitaux 10e dépôt
chez nous la sa des barbus 469% alors
vous misez sur quoi pour les désengorger
parce qu'on est loin du 90 minutes
produit à l'est en 2018 et vous avez
parlé de minium hôpitaux privés ben quoi
le privé peut aider rapidement le
maintenant ok bon d'abord je pense que
tout le monde qui nous écoutent qu'on
reprenne que ya des résultats de la
pandémie deuxièmement je reviens sur ce
qu'on disait sur les médecins de famille
tant que les québécois rompois taussac
c'est un groupe de médecine de famille
actuellement dans les urgences y est la
moitié des patients qui auraient dû être
traité dans une clinique des problèmes
mineurs donc il faut avec la fmq avec
les omnipraticiens
s'assurer qu'ils aient une meilleure
prise en charge dans les cliniques pour
cris québécois rrq pas besoin d'aller à
l'urgence on a commencé à le faire quand
la pandémie a diminué pour vos continuer
de le faire autres listes d'attentes
45000 personnes attendent des soins à
domicile
ce matin vous avez annoncé 900 millions
en quatre ans monde est loin des 3
milliards réclamée de toutes parts les
groupes d'experts de personnes âgées des
aînés et même selon l'attitude du québec
doit on est des camps comme affaires de
soins à domicile 1 quand il y en a qui
disent 3 milliards je voudrais qu'il
m'explique où ils vont reprendre des
infirmières ça tient pas debout nous ce
qu'on avait premier en 2018 c'était
d'augmenter les budgets des soins dont
celle de 800 millions on les augmenter
de 2 milliards depuis quatre ans que
l'on on promet d augmenter au total de
plus 3 milliards donc on est investi au
fur et à mesure que des infirmières
ajouté dans les soins et les services à
domicile et 45000 personnes qui
attendent des soins les maisons sont
ouverts aux suggestions
ce que je vous dis ces convois y aller
graduellement au fur et à mesure encore
là on a mis des incitatifs dans les
sujets pour que plus de jeunes
s'inscrivent en sciences infirmières on
à midi boni pour que les infirmières
retraitées reviennent donc encore là la
pensée magique de certains lobbys
mais là quand même l'autre les attentes
c'est les quatre mille trois cent trente
personnes pour les ch et celle des alors
c'est un mode d'hébergement il faut les
convaincre qu'il n'y avait rien qui
était fait dans les quatre années avant
qu'on arrive nous on a mis en place des
maisons des aînés qui sont en cours de
construction pour ajouter 2500 places
enfin donc ce temps court et vieux du
monde qui disent oh ben ça coûte trop
chalets maisons des années c'est trop
les maisons des aînés écoutez la
décennie structure boxe au québec
d'aujourd'hui moi je trouve que rien
thrombo nous et n'est
trop beau pour nos enix attendent des
réponses c'est qu'il ya dans certains
endroits les maisons des aînés certaines
femmes ont pris jusqu'à 1 million de
dollars par chambre dans certains cas la
liste d'attentes pour le siège s'il dit
qu'il faut nécessairement le mode idéal
les gens disposent les petits qu elle a
augmenté cette les attractions la maison
d'amy répondent pas la main des
gouvernements précédents mais tu es 3 4
personnes par chambre nous on met une
personne par chambre il ya des services
soucis qui ont été ajustés suite à la
pandémie donc oui les maisons des années
sont belles puis je suis très content de
toi et 14 ans maintenant annoncer un par
chambre dans la maison des aînés c'est
dans la salle il y en a encore kappa
chan ok très bien je les suivrai vous le
souligne anne marie est faible on a vous
avez autorisé conre plat je lise en tout
début d'émission quatre personnes âgées
par chambre vous voulez pas vous
retrouver le moins non plus quatre
personnes tous nous là on implique que
tout le monde d'abord
augmenter l'is ou un pli services à
domicile parce que la grande majorité
des québécois ils veulent vieillit à la
maison par contre il arrive un moment où
les personnes ont plus d'autonomie faut
aller dans une maison des aînés dont fo
les deux faut promettre sans nos
poussées ont deux petites très copieux
legourd passeport vaccinale est ce que
vous pourriez leur est imposé 7 supports
prévus ce pot prévu avec la vaccination
s'est heureusement pas prévu parce que
le président est en vous l'exclu est pas
parce qu on ne sait jamais se pose
cependant nos plats puis on pense pas
est obligé d'y arriver parce que la
vaccination fait que même ceux qui
attrapent la cabine ils sont beaucoup
moins malade que ceux qui ont été
vaccinés donc je lance le message après
cinq mois s'il vous plaît allez chercher
un nouveau vaccin céline vous parlez du
troisième ligne les gens de montréal et
c'est ce qui aiderait les gens de tout
le québec monsieur legault c'est si on
avait des chiffres sur la table d'ici le
3 octobre vous vous engagez à déposer ce
que vous avez comme aidé ce don loin
c'est dépassé avec la pandémie mais avec
la pandémie il ya beaucoup plus de monde
qui font du télétravail
donc les chiffres doivent être mis à
jour on ne peut pas sortir des chiffres
qui ne sont plus prouverait que la
mariée pas benoît même avec ça non non
prouvé qu'on avait besoin que 6 voix
l'un de l'autre on aurait dû le projet à
quatre voies mais c'est clair qu'on a
besoin d'un troisième gain en québec
donc dès jeudi s'il trop jeune et vous
l'aimerez pas celle là beaucoup de gens
ont souligné votre arrogance face à
toute forme
face à toute forme d'opposition
l'assemblée nationale
si vous avez 100 102 députés est ce que
vous seriez plus arrogant écoutez
d'abord la
la pandémie me rendis me rendue très
humble parce que au fur et à mesure que
la pandémie évolue l on avait de
l'information additionnelle puis parfois
ce que j'avais déjà ça ne passait là
fallait corriger donc fallait mettre son
orgueil de côté puis est capable de
s'ajuster donc et j'ai fait des points
de presse 7 jours sur 7 ou le second
train vous le savez très bien monsieur
roy donc 2 et star game je veux pas par
la personne choisie des propositions du
journal et vous savez ce qu'on veut dire
t'es pas d'un que l'assemblée siègerait
peau je leur parlais au téléphone je
réponde à leurs questions par téléphone
et après on ne recommence à ses jupes et
on a commencé à avoir des périodes de
questions là de vous écoutez trop le
spin de centaines d'objets je n'écoute
pas personnel mais monsieur legault il
ya une promesse que vous aviez fait
c'était de monter le mode de scrutin
devait même signer avec les autres
partis que dites-vous aux ce soir à tous
ceux qui ne votent pas nécessairement
pour la 4 puis c'est peut-être une
majorité de gens qui votent pas pour la
cac mais si j'en ai ont cru à cette
promesse là qu'ils ont sur tout cru
qu'ils allaient être mieux représentés
être représentées équitablement à
l'assemblée nationale pourquoi avoir
annoncé la bande avait promis de déposer
un projet de loi prend 0,39 qui a été
déposé
ensuite on a un premier de consulter est
arrivée la pandémie ok donc on a retardé
la consultation puis honnêtement on
s'est rendu compte que ça intéresse à
peu près personne n'y a personne qui se
boit des autobus au québec pour changer
de mode de scrutin mais celle qui
réussit actuellement il ya trop de
priorités autres pour mettre ça dans nos
priorités est
donc dans ce sens là on a décidé de
mettre ça de côté parce que on écouter
la population puis ça intéresse pas
population à part quelques intellectuels
le changement le mode de scrutin
s'intéressent pas les québécois
le logo merci beaucoup c'est tout
on se voit au débat sur vos des
bolincheurs le 22e merci monsieur
legault bercy beaucoup bonne campagne
merci vous poussez prochaine chef invité
dominique anglade du parti libéral du
québec
on a parcouru toutes les régions du
québec qu'on a été l écoute on a produit
la charte des régions et aujourd'hui il
ya un livre qu'on a écrit ensemble le
livre libéral
[Musique]
quand on entreprend un virage comme
celui-là ça prendre ça prend un certain
temps et puis c'est pas facile une idée
là dedans c'est de prendre un peu de
recul pour le parti libéral puis de se
dire comment est ce qu'on voit l'avenir
comment est-ce qu'on va reconnecter avec
la population
[Musique]
on s'est prononcé contre la loi 21 pas
parce qu'on est content la laïcité mais
contre certains articles et également
contre manière dont ça a été fait il
faut toujours se préoccuper du fait
français au québec toujours se
préoccuper du fait français on est quand
même 2 % en amérique du nord alors il
faut le faire de manière inclusive
personne ne peut s'appeler en partie de
l'économie s'il n'est pas capable de
reconnaît que le frein principal
aujourd'hui à notre développement
économique c'est la pénurie des deux
madame anglade bonsoir bonsoir comme on
l'a fait avec françois legault va le
faire avec tous les chefs patrice le
disait parlons d'abord du climat assez
toxique de cette campagne donc votre
candidate marois res qui a reçu des
menaces de mort ce qui était extrêmement
troublant mais elle a mis la faute elle
a pointé du doigt le chef conservateur
eric jam est ce que vous le tenez
responsable vous aussi de ce climat ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui madame madame
galipeau c'est toute la violence qui se
fait sur les médias sociaux qui se
prolonge maintenant dans la vie réelle
et je pense au contraire que ce que ça
nous prend c'est qu'il faut calmer le
jeu il faut calmer le jeu et à plusieurs
reprises j'ai dit qu'il fallait
justement parler à l'ensemble de tout le
monde avait une responsabilité à un rôle
à jouer une responsabilité à prendre et
on a demandé de calmer jeu et pour qu'on
puisse avoir une campagne qui soit
sereine puis vous savez comme moi que la
question de la violence passe et pas
seulement par rapport à l'est des votes
député c'est également dans nos rues
dans nos rues à maurienne dans nos rues
à laval et ça ça nous prend ça nous
prend non seulement les forts des corps
policiers mais également un effort de
prévention bien accrue pour pouvoir
vraiment mettre fin à cette violence
convient présent donc est ce qu'elle est
allée un peu trop loin peut-être je
pense qu'on n'est pas dans une situation
où on doit dire c'est la faute de untel
ou c'est la faute d'untel on doit calmer
joué à ce moment ci pour faire en sorte
que plus collectivement passer à travers
cette situation et trouver de véritables
solutions il en existe des solutions
dans le domaine de la violence et c'est
pour ça qu'on recommande encore une fois
beaucoup plus de prévention que ce qui
est fait aujourd'hui très bien de la
mangue ladd des dépenses de 41 milliards
de dollars sur cinq ans est ce que vous
allez par plonger le québec dans des
dauphins du déficit et on sait à quel
point ça a été douloureux pour s'en
sortir votre parti s'en souvient
particulièrement absolument pas partout
où je vais dans toutes les régions du
québec cependant temps c'est la chose
suivante c'est la difficulté à joindre
les deux bouts pour la classe la classe
moyenne québécoise on doit choisir entre
faire l'épicerie ou payer son loyer ou
envoyer ses enfants dans une activité on
est au québec en 2020 2 on n'a pas à
faire ses choix la responsabilité du
gouvernement c'est justement de donner
de l'oxygène à la classe moyenne
québécoise c'est ce qu'on fait avec le
cadre financier qu'on a présenté avec
des mesures qui sont concrètes qui
touchent les familles québécoises et qui
touche nos aînés parce que la seule
chose qui augmente aujourd'hui c'est le
revenu de nos aînés et on a une
responsabilité par rapport à par rapport
à l'ensemble de la population et pour y
arriver on a présenté un cadre un cadre
financier qui était responsable et je
vous dirai plus il était équitable il
est équitable parce qu'il fait en sorte
qu'on va générer de nouveaux revenus
avec on va taxer les très riches on va
taxer on va aller chercher de l'argent
dans les paradis fiscaux pour financer
une partie de ces dépenses là mais
encore une fois le ratio 2 par rapport à
la dette reste on continue de descendre
quand même 41 milliards ceku large et
c'est que c'est beaucoup d'argent mais
c'est nécessaire parce que la crise
actuellement elle est importante et
pendant que les coffres du québec sans
augmente les que l'argent augmente dans
les com du québec mais en fait les
poches des québécois se vide et nous on
estime que le rôle de l'état québécois
c'est justement de soutenir la rigueur
du delaware l'austérité c'est plus une
priorité pour on est dans un contexte
complètement différent aujourd'hui et la
nécessité de faire face à la crise de
l'inflation elle est importante elle est
fondamentale et nous on va être là on
doit être là pour répondre à ses besoins
j'ai entendu françois legault dire que
c'était irresponsable que d'aider ces
familles québécoises de manière accrue
nous on pense au contraire qu'on a le
devoir de le faire
parlons de nos engagements parce que
vous promettez donc des baisses d'impôts
comme la caq vous promettez aussi la
location pour les aînés comme la caq ça
se vaut deux gros poste budgétaire et
vous présenter malgré tout comme le
parti de l'économie vous l'avais dit en
lançant votre campagne
mais on a du mal à comprendre ce qui
vous démarque au fond alors ce qui vous
distingue
qu'est ce que c'est le parti libéral
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui vous démarque
par rapport à la cac on ne peut pas se
prétendre être le parti de l'économie
quand on ne reconnaît pas de manière
essentielle l'enjeu numéro un qui est la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre aujourd'hui au
québec partout vous allez donc service
public ne sont pas capables de suffire à
la demande on n'a pas suffisamment
preuve dans les classes vous savez
aujourd'hui on laisse les enfants
maisons sont rentrés à l'école il manque
de profs il manque d'infirmières il
manque une honte de tout et nos
entreprises n'ont pas suffisamment
d'employés hier on était j'étais encore
en abitibi témiscamingue et nous disait
si j'étais capable d'embaucher 50
personnes de plus je le ferai je ne suis
pas capable et ça ce n'est pas
considérable sur l'économie alors si on
veut parler d'économie si on veut être
conséquent il faut reconnaître la
pénurie de main-d'oeuvre et françois
legault nous a répété à maintes reprises
que cette pénurie de main d'oeuvre était
une bonne nouvelle ce n'est pas une
bonne nouvelle madame galipeau ça a des
conséquences directes sur notre capacité
à se développer et accroître au québec
et ça ça nous différencie grandement de
ce que la caq fait et j'aurai d'autres
éléments a vu sa portée quant à la
différenciation par rapport à la can
donc vous restez le parti d'économies
vous cesser le parti libéral de 2022
absolument d'autant plus que tout la
question par rapport à la lutte aux
changements climatiques elle est
importante on a un potentiel de
croissance économique liés à la lutte
aux changements climatiques qui est
significatif et ça ce n'est pas du tout
considérés du côté du côté de la cac on
va certainement y revenir vous parliez
de la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre justement
bon immigration vous fixé un seuil à
70000 immigrants par année c'est une de
vos solutions mais est ce que vous
pourriez augmenter ce seuil
soixante dix mille migrants c'est
aujourd'hui ce qu'on accueille au québec
aujourd'hui à l'heure où on se parle
cette année en 2022 on est capable de le
faire alors ce qu'on dit c'est que
évidemment au maintien ce chiffre mais
après il faut s'entendre avec chacune
des régions il faut qu'on régionalise
l'immigration et pour la régionaliser il
faut que les régions soient elles-mêmes
interpellé ce qu'on a mis de l'avant
c'est l'idée d'avoir une charte des
régions que chaque région puisse se
prononcer plus dire voici qu'on met
personne nous sommes capables
d'accueillir et ensemble on va
déterminer par la suite après la
première année combien de personnes on
devrait déjà difficile d'accueillir il
ya eu manque de logement ils manquent de
tout dans les régions mais ça veut dire
que vous pourriez augmenter ce seuil jeu
ça va dépendre des régions ça dépendra
ça dépendra pas de québec s'est pas
québec qui doit qui doit imposer sa
manière de faire aux différentes régions
du québec mais c'est bien haut les gens
d'être interpellé ce qu'on veut c'est un
style de leadership à gérer est ce que
vous êtes prête à aller où 80 g le
chiffre c'est 70 milles et par la suite
c'est une sorte de leadership qui est
différent vaut si madame galipeau c'est
on n'est pas en train de créer une
chicane avec le maire de québec où avec
la mairesse de montréal ce qu'on veut
c'est avoir un rapport de cohabitation
de collaboration dans lequel on est
capables de se parler de sang temps de
discuter et d'établir ce qui est mieux
pour le québec et pour la région
concernée on est en campagne électorale
voulez pas vous comme être sur un
chiffre aller jusqu'où vous pourriez
années 60 70 milles pour la première
année riche il est ensuite jean suite et
ensuite la charte des régions qui sera
adopté la première année qui nous
permettrait d'avoir ses relations avec
chacune des régions du québec la
langlade vous avez manifesté dans la rue
avec la communauté anglophone contre le
projet de loi 96 la réforme des lois
serre et récemment selon statistique
canada le français recule des chiffres
inquiétants
du moins est-ce que ces chiffres vous
inquiète puis est ce que ça vous pousse
à revoir votre position contre cette loi
la question du français sera toujours
fondamental au québec on est 2 % de
francophones en amérique du nord mais on
peut être pour la protection du français
pour la promotion du français et est
contre le projet de loi 96 qu'est ce que
vous n'aimez pas dedans le projet de loi
96 divise les québécois comme moi je ne
je ne conçois pas qu'on dise à nos
jeunes adultes qui devront choisir un
cégep en français versus assiégé pendant
qu'ils ont le droit de faire c'est
prendre cette décision là eux-mêmes
c'est un exemple deuxième exemple vous
accueillez des gens et puis vous dites
mais à bout de six mois s'est terminée
vous devez avoir appris le français
s'est même pas réalisé à combien de
personnes qui sont venues dire à quel
point c'était aucunement réaliste il ya
plusieurs éléments du projet de loi 96
qui ne tiennent pas la route c'est pour
ça qu'on a voté contre et notre
formation politique elle veut pas
diviser les québécois elle veut
rassembler l'équipe mais pour bien vous
comprendre parce que monsieur legault
tout à l'heure ne faisait que six mois
c'est déjà presque un privilège puisque
partout dans le monde les états
s'adresse dans la langue du pays aux
nouveaux arrivants mais ma question
c'est est-ce que vous avec vous voulez
avec ces chiffres en faire plus pour
protéger le français
ou en faire - ou si vous êtes élu
suspendre la loi l'abolir alors
premièrement il faut toujours en faire
il faut toujours à faire davantage et
c'est la raison pour laquelle on a fait
27 propositions en matière de français
vous savez comme moi que la question du
français se posent notamment dans le
centre-ville de montréal se pose parce
que il y en a on a nos institutions
anglophones ya plusieurs mesures qu'on
propose pour aller francisé directement
dans le centre-ville de montréal donc il
faut prendre ça non seulement à coeur
mais avec des objectifs très concrets
pour le projet de loi 96 on s'est opposé
parce qu'on estime qu'il devrait pas y
avoir de clause nonobstant on estime
également qu' il devrait pas y avoir les
limites qu'ils ont imposée pour les
cégeps justement parce qu'à des jeunes
francophones qui peuvent décider d'aller
étudier en anglais la même chose pour
les pour les peaux l'immigration alors
vous êtes élu vous vous abonnez c'est
cette fois l'heure vous éliminez la
clause dérogatoire vous ouvrez de
l'amant pas de restriction pour les
cégeps cela dit le monde des affaires en
ce moment surtout dans les technologies
vous avez évoqué montréal estime que la
loi 96 menace de causer des dommages à
l'économie de la loi ferait plus de tort
que de bien est ce que vous allez cédé
devant leurs revendications c'est pas
une histoire de céder devant les
revendications c'est une sorte de
comprendre qu'aujourd'hui on est en
pénurie de main d'oeuvre importante est
que toutes ces entrepreneurs à tous ces
entrepreneurs là qui en passant sont
bien souvent des francophones se rendent
bien compte qu'on n'est pas capable
d'attirer du talent qui nous manque de
mon nid manque de monde partout et qu'on
ait pas suffisamment compétitifs à
l'échelle à l'échelle globale et qu'on a
besoin de monde dans nos services
publics comme dans nos entreprises alors
ce qu'il faut c'est trouver les mais en
voyant un message de dire au québec on
est accueillant au québec ça se passe en
français voici comment on va y arriver
voici les mesures que l'on va mettre en
place dans le centre ville de montréal
voici comme on va francisé l'importance
de l' esprit de l'importance de la
régionalisation de l'immigration aussi
parce que pour franciser il faut aussi
régionalisés l'autre dimension
identitaire culturelle c'est la laïcité
vous vous opposez la loi 21 le port de
signes religieux ostentatoires donc les
personnes en autorité qu'est ce que vous
faites si vous êtes élu vous l'abolisse
est complètement on enlève on enlève la
clause d'un obstant parce qu'on est
opposés au fait qu'il ya une chose dont
900 qui soit mise avant même que ça
passe le test des tribunaux et dans un
second temps dans on n'a aucun besoin
d'avoir cette loi dans nous dans nos
écoles pour les enseignants alors pour
laisser une religion pour les cours pour
les enseignants ce n'est pas ce qu'on
les juge police et les autres on le
laisse on laisse de cette manière là et
les tribunaux auront à se prononcer si
vous éliminez la clause d'option qui
peut être un peu technique pour les
téléspectateurs ça faisait que dans cinq
ans le débarquement sérieux qui a pas de
restriction ça veut dire que ça va
passer le test des tribunaux on vit dans
une démocratie il est normal que pour
une loi comme celle là est pas ce test
des tribunaux ceci ne veut pas dire
qu'on est content la laïcité au
contraire je pense que les offres très
en faveur de l'ailé est ce que c'est sur
ces deux aspects la langue et la laïcité
qui sont des questions identitaires est
ce que ça peut expliquer le faible taux
d'intentions de vote chez les
francophones en ce moment pour le parti
libéral et je vous dirais que lorsque je
regarde dans les différentes régions du
québec ce de quoi on ne peut pas les
enjeux dans ton pour lesquelles on nous
interpelle c'est toute la question de
l'inflation c'est toute la question de
la pénurie de main d'oeuvre c'est toute
la question lie à la lutte aux
changements climatiques
tu penses que c'est ces enjeux là qu'ils
vont répondre aux besoins des
différentes régions du québec également
madame anglade parlons climat mais
environnement ben je vais commencer avec
ce qui est devenu un symbole une marque
de division le trop fameux troisième
lien vous ce serait si j'ai bien compris
un tramway avec un tunnel aussi mais pas
de ton pour vous juste m'expliquer là
qu'est ce que vous feriez la première
chose que je vais vous dire par rapport
au troisième l'insee que ce qui est
présenté là n'a aucun sens enfin par la
cac le tunnel sous le fleuve sans étude
sauriez vous l'avez vous même souligner
à quel point ça ne tient pas la route ce
qu'on dit c'est qu'un tramway à québec
qui va est ouest ce qu'on aimerait faire
c'est qu'il a également nord-sud et
qu'on puisse aller de l'autre côté de la
rive jusqu'à lévis avec le tramway
qu'obama mais comment ça va nécessiter
des études pour nous dire quel va être
le meilleur tracé est la meilleure
manière d'y arriver mais l'ol donc vous
aussi vous êtes dans un tube on n'est
pas nécessairement dans un tunnel ça
pourrait être pour ça pourrait
différentes alternatives il va falloir
qu'on ait des études qui soit vraiment
cohérent pour pouvoir nous proposer pour
vont nous dire dans quelle direction va
s'en aller dans ce cas là vous savez
vous savez monsieur roy fait je suis
ingénieur de formation l'année les plans
les devis j'en ai vu dans la vie des
études il nous faut des études pour ça
pour savoir quel est le meilleur tracé
et c'est possible sur la nécessité
d'abord du troisième lieu où vous en
êtes où la sq on a besoin ou pas il ya
la nécessité d'améliorer la mobilité à
québec il ya une nécessité de réduire le
trafic à une nécessité d'avoir osé mener
ou pas ça va dépendre encore une fois
des études qui vont être faites mais ce
ce que ce que je dis c'est que pour une
capitale nationale aussi importante que
québec ça nous prend un réseau de
transport collectif important il faut
aller dans cette direction là et pour
savoir quel tracé on va faire de la
quelle manière on va le faire ça nous
prend des études il y aurait peut-être
rien au bout des études je te suis
dépendant des études mais qu il pourrait
aussi y avoir une manière de faire en
sorte que le transport comme se rendre
jusqu'à aller vite ça aussi ça va être
important d'accord mais si les études
disent le tunnel bien ajouter des
voitures vous n'excluez rien autrement
dit vous attendez de voir des études on
attend la science nous à la science va
aussi nulle idée là dedans et je pense
que la science est le meilleur vecteur
de décision le gouvernement legault a
mis une croix sur l'exploitation des
ressources naturelles ici mais quant au
transport soit du gaz ou du pétrole est
ce que vous c'est terminé a jamais il
ira jamais depuis plaignent que ce soit
un future energy est ce qui reviendrait
ou en gnl québec pour l'édification des
dégâts naturels vous c'est non ou c'est
peut-être c'est terminé déjà vous dire
pourquoi c'est terminé on est au 21ème
siècle la lutte aux changements
climatiques c'est l'enjeu du 21e siècle
et nous on voit un énorme potentiel de
développement économique avec cette
lutte aux changements climatiques
ce qui veut dire qu'on doit investir
dans le solaire qu'on doit investir dans
l'éolien qu'on doit investir dans
l'économie d'énergie qu'on doit verser
dans l'hydrogène vers l'hydrogène verts
qui va faire en sorte que on va être
capable d'avoir des transports lourds
qui n'émettent pas de gaz à effet de
serre on va avoir des usines qui sont
capables de ne plus émettre de gaz à
effet de serre parce qu'on aura investi
dans l'hydrogène avait plus de tuyaux
aucun projet ne passerait la rampe on
lit l'idée là dedans c'est que tout
allait dans la direction d'éliminer les
hydrocarbures et au québec on consomme
45% d'hydrocarbures il faut tout faire
pour faire en sorte que ce 45% soit ou
bien électrifiées ou bien remplacé par
l'hydrogène vers vous ne proposez pas
sauf erreur une taxe pour les
propriétaires de grosses cylindrées
devait us québec solidaire a proposé des
choses 15% on en parlera plus tard
pourquoi vous ne proposez pas ça
justement aujourd'hui la les québécois
dans le contexte actuel ne sont pris à
la gorge sont pris à la gorge et c'est
tout à leur dois faire des choix qui
sont déchirants entre l'épicerie et puis
et puis pillé loyer ce qu'on pense qu'il
doit être fait c'est une véritable lutte
aux changements climatiques
et si on est sérieux par rapport à cette
lutte aux changements climatiques ça
peut pas être la responsabilité d'un
ministre parmi 28 ça doit être la
responsabilité de la première ministre
c'est pour ça que je m'engage à porter
cet enjeu là et en faire un véritable
projet de développement économique pour
quelque chose d'incitatif pour j'en
étais à faire payer les citoyens qui
pollue plus d'enfoncer soliver us vous
êtes en europe olonne non pas dans le
contexte actuel aujourd'hui parce que on
n'est pas encore une fois les québécois
sont pris à la gorge on a besoin de
donner de l'oxygène à la classe moyenne
québécoise on a beaucoup parlé on en
parlait plutôt de la fonderie horne
là vous dites la fonderie doit tendre
vers la norme d'arsenic de 3 nanogrammes
par mètre cube
si ils arrivent pas parlons d'abord du
15 s'il n'avait pas est-ce que vous
acceptez le 15 en cinq ans vous c'est
acceptable moi ce que j'aimerais voir
c'est qu'on soit capable d'aller
atteindre la norme ses seules et 6 vols
il propose 15 dans cinq ans est ce que
vous êtes ok on vous laisse aller
pendant cinq ans moi j'aimerais qu'on
s'asseye avec et l'équipe de
l'entreprise et les citoyens pour dire
en quelle direction va s'en aller parce
que pourquoi est-ce que c'est acceptable
d'avoir une norme quelque part est
différent quelque chose de différent à
roanne votre gouvernement
celui à 20 celui à 20 celui avant
accepter ça c'est pas depuis hier quand
on sait que la fonderie rond le pollue
donc vous ne l'affirmé pas où vous la
fermez s'ils n'arrivent pas vous dire
qu'on arrive à 15 demain matin je suis
convaincu qu'on est capable de trouver
une solution qui va faire en sorte qu'on
va se rendre à troyes mais j'aimerais
dire par contre si non madame englobe
mais il dit cela parce que j'aimerais
juste mentionné par rapport à 2010 neuf
qu'il ya un rapport qui est sorti parce
que vous dites ça fait longtemps qu'on
sait qu'il ya quand même un rapport qui
est sorti en 2019 qui disait que ça
touchait la santé directs des des
québécois et que délibérément le
gouvernement n'a pas fourni cette
information est que si les journalistes
n'avaient pas fait un bon travail
aujourd'hui on serait même pas en train
de parler de cet enjeu là et ça c'est
extrêmement prenez vous ne fermez pas
l'usiné au nom on ne ferme pas les
usines on parle avec les acteurs et on
trouve une solution pour ça et en
attendant dans l'âme anglade ya des gens
qui souffrent qui s'inquiètent et qui
voit cette cette norme qui dépasse ce
que ça devrait être et puis ce 10 mai
non ville aux enfants vivent l'os a des
conséquences sur nos enfants nous
demande d'attendre encore des années
mais je parlais hier à ars nova rollin
qui habitent là mais notre candidat qui
a d'être sûr parce qu'à ses enfants sur
place et ce qu'il nous dit c'est ce qui
nous dérange le plus c'est de pas avoir
d'informations ce qui nous dérange le
plus c'est qu'on n'ait pas de plan
d'action ce qui nous dérange le plus
c'est qu'on soit laissée dans la
noirceur et qu'on a l'impression que le
gouvernement ne partage pas des
informations qu'on puisse s'asseoir tout
le monde ensemble y avait une réunion de
la santé publique il ya deux jours à
rouyn noranda et les gens disent on n'a
pas toute l'information dont on a besoin
assurons-nous de la transparence
assurons-nous de développer à prendre un
plan match collaboration doit arriver à
une solution n'a langlade jean charest
l'avait promis philippe couillard
l'avait promis aussi françois legault
l'avait promis il a dû reculer vous
promettez à votre tour un 25 familles
pour chaque québécois ces jeux je ris
parce que j'ai l'impression que plus
personne n'y croit cette promesse là
alors pourquoi est ce que vous vous
allez réussir là où tout le monde a
échoué on n'a pas le droit de laisser
tomber un million de québécois tout à
l'heure vous parliez de 400000 personnes
qui avaient sur la liste d'attentes en
2000 ans en 2004 en 2018 et aujourd'hui
on est rendu à plus de deux millions
c'est pas 800 milles c'est plus d'un
million parce que il s'agit de personnes
qui n'ont toujours pas accès un médecin
de famille le même médecin de famille de
manière régulière on n'a pas le droit
moral de laisser tomber un million de
québécois alors la première chose à
faire c'est d'établir des objectifs puis
la deuxième chose c'est de dire comment
nous allons faire le commun évidemment
la question du recrutement du nombre de
médecins reconnaître qu'il ya une
pénurie reconnaître nous manque deux des
fermières de super infirmières
reconnaître aussi l'importance de la
reconnaissance des diplômes les
activités qui sont présentement fait
dans les hôpitaux comment est ce qu'on
les ramène dans les cliniques mais la
dernière chose qu'on a besoin de faire
c'est de baisser les bras il faut au
contraire se tenir debout mais dire qu
on abandonnera pas cette idée parce
qu'il en va de la santé globale de tous
les québécois et vous pensez que les
québécois vous entendez vous écoute
parce que c'est vous chacun arrive avec
des solutions et on n'y arrive jamais je
pense que nico l'état qui a 72 ans
aujourd'hui à laquelle je parlais et qui
me disait qu'elle a une maladie
chronique que son médecin de famille a
pris sa retraite et qu'aujourd'hui elle
est incapable d'avoir un rendez vous
qu'elle est incapable de voir quelqu'un
et qu'elle a développé cette relation
avec son médecin de famille et qu'elle
ne devrait pouvoir retrouver un autre je
pense que elle elle veut entendre qu'on
a quelqu'un qui se préoccupe de sa et
son parti libéral on va s'en préoccuper
la première semaine de campagne
maintenant terminées ce soit ça a été
difficile pour vous mais plusieurs ont
souligné les difficultés de candidature
en fin de tout ça porte justement bien
passé pour vous cette semaine est ce que
quand vous regardez aussi les sondages
vous avez l'impression de jouer leur
va-tout du parti libéral c'est sûr servi
de base mais est ce que vous vous battez
pour la survie de votre parti en ce
moment on est amené mme dussault la
seule formation politique à avoir
présenté une plateforme électorale avoir
présenté un cadre budgétaire et 225
candidats pour moi ce que je vois c'est
une formation politique qui est collé à
ce qui se passe sur le terrain avec des
propositions concrètes en matière de de
lutte par rapport à la crise de
l'inflation d'un véritable lutte par
rapport à la main d'oeuvre et par
rapport au changement climatique alors
je vous dirais que on est dans une
première semaine de campagne il en
resterait qu il reste 4 et c'est aller à
la rencontre des québécois avec les
propositions concrètes que nous avons
mis de l'avant parce que votre avenir
politique est liée aux résultats
l'élection du 4 octobre vous savez tout
ce que j'ai fait dans ma vie ça a
toujours été ça toujours été un défi
quand j'ai décidé de me présenter à la
chefferie du parti libéral c'est pas
parce que c'était facile c'est parce que
le défi en valait la peine c'est parce
que je crois pertinemment qu'au québec
on est capable de régler l'enjeu pénurie
de main d'oeuvre et de faire en sorte
qu' on est des enseignants et qu'on
puisse régler l'accès à un médecin de
famille c'est parce que je crois qu'on
est capable de lutter pour des
changements climatiques et de
véritablement développer un projet de
société qui va faire en sorte qu'on a
développé une économie en arrière de ça
on le fait parce qu'on n'y croit
fondamentalement et c'est ce qu'on va
démontrer au cours des quatre prochaines
semaines madame en anglais monsieur
legault point mma dernière j'aimerais
pas ma dernière je vous avertis quand
vous lisez les journaux quand vous
regardez les téléjournaux est-ce que
secrètement le matin où vous êtes
j'aurais peut-être pas dû quitter la cac
pas une fois dans ma vie pas une fois
dans ma vie ça m'est arrivé vous savez
pourquoi parce que c'est une question de
valeur parce que c'est une question de
si on en croit quand on croque roi
qu'est ce qui vous est l'inclusion le
fait que tous les québécois peuvent
aspirer à être québécois est tout ce
qu'ils peuvent être le fait qu' on soit
capable de dire aux gens lors on arrête
de diviser les québécois entre
anglophones et francophones et
immigrants non immigrants en ce qu'ils
font 56 1000 $ et moins de cinquante six
mille dollars moi tous les jours de ma
vie je vais me lever pour faire en sorte
que tous les québécois aient leur place
autour de la table et qu'ils puissent y
contribuer pas un jour de ma vie j'ai
regretté jusqu'au bout jusqu'au dernier
jour jusqu'au dernier jour récemment
merci beaucoup de vous êtes prêté à
l'exercice merci prochain chef vers siel
campagne merci à vous au prochain chef
invité gabriel nadeau dubois de québec
solidaire
l'histoire de québec solidaire là c'est
quoi c'est l'histoire de gens qui ont le
vent dans la face que tout le monde
pense que ça marchera pas les enfants
qui finissent par y arriver
[Musique]
québec aurait tout pour être le champion
du monde la transition écologique
malheureusement l'obsession de françois
legault pour le troisième ligne et nous
en empêche depuis quelques jours notre
ministre succombé à l'un de ses pires
défauts s'est mis à faire sa meilleure
imitation de maurice duplessis il s'est
autoproclamé père de la nation
québécoise
[Musique]
on a un premier ministre
donc qu'ils s'attribuent ce qui va bien
ce lave les mains de ce qui va mal moi
je trouve sa loge pas sur le goût et
propriétaire du nationalisme québécois
moi ce qui me rend fier au québec
c'est que de vivre dans une saisie de
justice sociale de vivre dans une
société
d'inclusion où on oublie bras au lieu de
pointer du doigt
bonsoir monsieur nadeau dubois bonsoir
quelle est la responsabilité des élus
dont vous êtes leur face à la colère
dirigée à leur endroit à votre endroit
je suis vraiment en colère des anti
système qui est dirigée compte et
gestion démocratique quand des personnes
sont à vue cette violence depuis
quelques jours quelques semaines quel
est donc votre responsabilité commune
lue je pense que notre première
responsabilité c'est de donner l'exemple
et de lancer un appel au calme je suis
heureux d'avoir entendu tous les chefs
de parti lancé cet appel au calme et là
dans les derniers jours mais je pense
que notre solution aussi notre notre
rôle c'est de trouver des solutions moi
je pense qu au lendemain je pense qu au
lendemain d'élections faut que ce soit
un chantier prioritaire au québec je
sais pas quel sera mon rôle le 4 octobre
au matin mais je pense qu'on a besoin
d'une vraie réflexion transpartisane qui
pourrait prendre la forme d'une
commission parlementaire à l'assemblée
nationale du québec pour dégager des
consensus et qu'on avance parce que moi
j'ai pas envie que la prochaine campagne
électorale soit pire que celle ci moi je
fais campagne avec ma fille en ce moment
j'ai vu ce qui est arrivé à marwari ce
qui a nourri coach connaît moi je peux
pas accepter que ça continue de
dégénérer ce climat de violence là et
que la prochaine campagne électorale
soit encore pire j'accepte passa donc
des mesures très concrètes très
rapidement au lendemain du 4e tour quel
que soit votre rôle est ce que vous
voyez déjà vous dites alternatives à
laquelle vous voyez déjà comme sur de
l'opposition moi je fais je fais pas de
la politique pour faire des épluchettes
de blé d'inde moi je veux je veux gagner
puis l'équipe de candidats que
maintenant et moi on a rassemblé c'est
pour gouverner le québec si l'équipe
québécoise me confie un autre mandat par
exemple celui d'être l'opposition
officielle dont on va l'accomplir avec
avec toute notre énergie aujourd'hui
vous avez rendu public votre plan
2030 changements de pratiques vision
2030 un plan très ambitieux on pourrait
lire un rapport du giec du groupe ii
pour les changements climatiques vous
êtes appuyé par des experts
universitaires et tous à 55 % de
réduction d'ici 2030 et dans huit ans le
7 mai matin on a fait 3 % en 30 ans
comment on peut faire autant en si peu
de temps c'est un défi mais on n'a pas
le choix vous avez raison on accumule du
retors en lutte aux changements
climatiques depuis des années à cause de
l'inaction des gouvernements libéraux
péquistes et khakis moi je suis au night
avec les québécois et québécoises lardy
fo ça change au québec si on veut
rattraper ce retard là ils notent plein
il est ambitieux oui mais il est
transparent au cache rien aux gens et il
est rigoureux il est chiffré il est
vérifiée et validée par huit experts
indépendants
on a fait nos devoirs ce plan là est
solide et mon message pour les québécois
et les québécoises et on est capable on
a de l'hydroélectricité de l'électricité
propre à nos revendre on est capable ou
québec d'être un des pays les plus chers
au monde sait ce que je pense c'est ce
que je crois c'est ce que je vais
répéter chaque jour mais vous avez même
d'aujourd'hui faux jeu on doit bousculer
les québécois là donc ça veut dire
demander des sacrifices avait même dit
guy laliberté les focus calme un peu
avec ses jets privés ya pourtant deux
des trois victimes un jeune au québec
mais par contre mesures 15% sur les b e
s on te dit tout à l'heure tu n'as pas
réaliste non plus moi je transparent
avec les gens je suis en est en ce
moment le livre us les véhicules ultra
polluants il y en a de plus en plus sur
les routes du québec il s'en vend de
plus en plus à chaque année est ce qu'on
peut continuer comme ça et être sérieux
dans notre lutte aux changements
climatiques la réponse est non mais vous
savez quoi on va le faire intelligemment
on voit exemptes et les familles
nombreuses parce qu'il ya des gens dont
beaucoup d'enfants tu peux pas rentrer
toute la petite amie dans une toyota
corolla cela prendrait je te crois sont
exemptes et les familles nombreuses on
va aussi exhorté les gens qui ont besoin
de ces véhicules là pour leur travail
c'est la moindre des choses
notre taxe sur les véhicules de tromper
les gens vont aussi avec modulé selon
les régions parce que en
abitibi-témiscamingue
la vie est pas la même qu'à montréal
donc ce sera un système modulée par
région mais oui on est en ait on est
transparent il faut que ça change au
québec si on veut atteindre nos cibles
de réduction degrés avec des sacrifices
c'est certain pour moi la transition
écologique c'est pô juste une question
de sacrifice on a aussi beaucoup à
gagner moi je pense que les gens au
québec nous y compris les québécoises et
québécois en ce qu'elles vivent dans les
banlieues leur projet de ville c'est
pour passer le plus de temps possible
dans le trafic ils veulent de la qualité
de vie ils veulent moins de temps dans
le trafic le matin puis plus de temps
avec les gens qu'ils aiment et pour moi
la révolution transports qu'on veut
faire à québec solidaire donné à tout le
monde des options transport écologique
dans toutes les villes dans toutes les
régions c'est pas des sacrifices c'est
un gain de qualité de vie moi je pense
qu'on est rendu là on est on a tout
tenté main pour être un des pays les
plus verts au monde moi c'est le projet
que je propose des transports notamment
cet important pour québec et distants
sont longs création de 2,2 destitution
là que québec rail québec bus céder quoi
des sociétés d'état vous allez remplacer
la compagnie orléans qu'est ce que vous
faites est juste sur un bus par jour
pour rester là qu'est ce que vous faites
exactement les employeurs au pays je
reviens de la gaze méprise aussi sony
région là auraient été abandonnés dans
les dernières années on leur a enlevé du
transport en commun alors qu'on devrait
en train d'agiter du service en
transport interurbain le privé a échoué
alors on va créer un transporteur public
par autocar qui va donner du bon service
de qualité abordables à toutes les
régions alors vous voulez aussi
pénaliser les industries polluantes la
100 dollars la tonne irez-vous qui a
fermé des entreprises comme la
cimenterie par exemple n'est gagné pour
saluer les pros question de fermer des
industries mais il faut que les plus
grands pollueurs du québec fassent leur
part on va modifier la bourse du carbone
pour atteindre nos cibles de réduction
de gaz à effet de serre on va s'assurer
d'accompagner les travailleurs
travailleuses parce que c est important
il pas question choisel perdent leur job
au québec parce qu'on fait le virage
vers une économie verte on va
requalifier les gens qui ont besoin de
se repositionner soit à l'intérieur
d'une entreprise ou dans une autre
industrie on va faire les choses comme
il faut mais on voit les frères parce
que moi je pense aux générations futures
je veux qu'on laisse le québec on s'est
encore possible que quoi la rassurer de
créer le large 64 me soit 1 15 milliard
notre plat ça représente des
investissements au total de 29 milliards
de dollars en infrastructures donc en
immobilisations dans un premier mandat
on est rendu là au québec il faut
investir ce qu'on propose aux québécois
québécoise c'est le plus grand chantier
depuis la révolution tranquille parce
qu'on est face au plus grand défi depuis
l'argent bien d'où des hausses d'impôts
l'argent va venir bien sûr à partie de
la bourse du carbone qui va générer des
revenus on va avoir une taxe sur les
grands pollueurs bref bon il est pas
question s'en prendre aux travailleurs
travailleuses ni à la classe moyenne
mais il faut qu'on avance il faut qu'on
lieu de pauvres est contre les
changements climatiques monsieur nadeau
dubois une petite supplémentaire
là-dessus avant de vous parler deux
langues d'immigration et de souveraineté
la fonderie ont eu 10 le mieux qu'on
peut faire c'est quinzaine au g dans
cinq ans est ce que vous les laisser
opérer pendant cinq ans oui ou non nous
on va leur demander d'atteindre la norme
québécois vous c'est trois quatre
prochaines années j'en ai demandé
d'atteindre ce fameux 15 dans nos g en
un an pourquoi parce que moi j'accepte
pas en 2022 de dire à des femmes
enceintes désole le petit bébé que dans
le ventre il va avoir un quotient
intellectuel peut-être plus bas qui va
peut-être mettre un peu plus petit parce
qu'on n'a pas le courage de dire à la
multinationale glencore qu'au québec la
santé ça passe un grand du profit dans
un an s'ils n'arrivent pas à 15 vous
mettez a créé n'a pas le pire scénario
possible ce n'est pas une fermeture est
une réduction temporaire des activités
de glencore et si on en arrive là si on
en arrive là on va compenser les
travailleurs travailleuses on va
compenser la ville de rouyn noranda moi
je pense j'ai la conviction que glencore
est capable d'arriver à respecter la
norme québécoise la député de rouyn
noranda et dans quelle partie est à
québec solidaire on est sur le terrain
ces gens là nous le dise la se faire
pourrir la vie avoir pas pour l'avenir
nous nous sommes allées de la porte est
ouverte ou fermée ça fait 40 ans
voulez vous l'avez poser la question
madame enghelab ça fait 40 ans que tous
les partis ferme les yeux ça vous ont
fait un mort en plus les yeux
souveraineté
votre démarche vers la souveraineté
votre assemblée constituante maine un
référendum sur la souveraineté premier
mandat le référendum oui parce que nous
on pense que pour la faire la transition
écologique pour la faire cette
réconciliation avec les peuples
autochtones du québec
il faut un nouveau système politique
qu'il faut un nouveau pacte
constitutionnel c'est l'engagement qu'on
a devant les québécois québécois donc
référendum d'ici quatre ans d'abord une
assemblée constituante pourquoi décider
de quoi il va avoir l'air ce pays là
pour assurer à tout le monde des droits
et libertés pour le rédiger de nation à
nation ce nouveau pacte avec les
premières nations les référendums dans
votre premier mandat cette constitution
l'autre ensuite oui soumis à un
référendum dans un premier mandat comme
d'ailleurs ça vient de faire au chili on
ne pas sortir le drapeau
laïcité vous êtes contre toute
interdiction de signes religieux
donc vous adorez le hacker canadien
dubreu donc après trois périodes de
crise de débats déchirants au québec
vous nous proposer une prolongation on
repart à zéro est ce que vous trouvez
que la game est terminée vous repart à
zéro moi je pense que le débat n'est pas
terminé la game d'un requin pas terminée
la loi peinture est contestée devant les
tribunaux ça continue de faire la marche
est la laïcité c'est important et la loi
21 voici ce qu'on va faire avec on va
garder ce que bon dans la loi 21 parce
que du bon s'affirmer la laïcité est
important l'inscrire dans notre charte
québécoise des droits et libertés c'est
important la séparation de l'église et
l'état cette importance au québec mais
empêchés à des femmes d'aller enseigner
dans nos écoles parce qu'il porte un
signe religieux je pense que c'est une
mauvaise idée il nous manque tellement
prof pourquoi on se priverait de femmes
qui veulent contribuer à nos systèmes
d'éducation
et migration vous avez dit hier on va en
accueillant on doit en accueillir plus
pour vous être plus précis votre seuil
d'immigration acceptable compte tenu de
l'intégration en france et au québec
ckoi 70 80 90 moi quand je me promène
dans les régions du québec tout le monde
me dit au manque de monde au manque de
monde on manque de monde partout la
capacité d'accueil du québec c'est ça
qui fait débat moi je suis tanné que ce
soit l'objet de petite politique parce
que quand on fait de la petite politique
avec l'immigration là nous ici on a
peut-être ben du fun mais il ya des gens
sur le terrain qui souffrent parce que
ça a tendance à alimenter les préjugés
moi je pense quand 70 et 80 mais
l'immigrant une grande par année sabin
du bon sens qui pour trancher la
question la capacité d'accueil exane du
québec on veut créer un comité large
d'experts qui va nous le dire en
fonction de l'économie de la langue la
culture c'est quoi cette capacité
d'accueil là on va suivre les
recommandations de ce comité là on voit
ça va contribuer à régler la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre on voit régionaliser
l'immigration on va faire la
francisation en milieu de travail bref
on va traiter les immigrés les
immigrants au québec comme des humains
pas comme des numéros donc vous dites
jusqu'à 80 donc le 50000 de monsieur
legault et leur baisser le seuil à 50
pour l'an prochain vous êtes c'est trop
peu c'était suffisant il manquerait pas
de monde partout au québec
c'est pas suffisant
parlons du coût de la vie vous voulez
suspendre la tvq sur tous les produits
de première nécessité on parle de
l'épicerie les vêtements des restaurants
et ça va aider en fait autant les riches
que les pauvres parce que les
millionnaires aussi ils vont au
restaurant qu'ils consomment alors
est-ce que ça va pas un peu à l'encontre
de vos principes d'aidés peut-être la
case moyens d'aider les personnes les
plus vulnérables
cette mesure-là de suspension de la tvq
est une mesure temporaire pour aider les
gens face à une inflation une poussée
inflationniste qui elle aussi est
temporaire il faut aider les gens le
monde arrive plus et moi je trouve pas
ça normal au québec qu'on taxe libyen
est essentielle dans un contexte où le
monde sont plus capable de s'acheter
l'idée essentielle ou encore bien des
gens ont de la difficulté à s'acheter
les biens essentiels c'est pour ça qu'on
a pris cet engagement lors mon équipe
économique et moi c'est une manière
concrète dinde et le monde sans se
priver de revenus sans baisser pour
toujours les impôts du québec parce que
j'ai entendu madame anglade et monsieur
legault propre promettent des baisses
d'impôts mur à mur là ça ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'on se prive
d'argent dont on a besoin pour prendre
soin de nos aînés pour reconstruire nos
écoles combien ce arrivé sur mon
environnement c'est un coude à peu près
deux milliards de dollars par année ce
qu'on cultive temporaire et notre cadre
financier
il sera à l'équilibré à québec solidaire
mais ce qu'il aurait fallu cibler plus
plus directement certaines personnes qui
en ont vraiment besoin il y aura aussi
des mesures ciblées mais il faut une
mesure d'urgence qui s'applique
rapidement pour aider les gens à arriver
à la fin du mois l'ont tellement qu'on
voit sur lequel ont voyagé pour la crise
du coût de la vie c'est la crise du
logement parce que c'est quoi le premier
poste de dépense de toutes les familles
au québec qu'elles soient locataires ou
propriétaires c'est le loyer l'hypothèse
avait plus pour des crises du coût de la
vie si on règle pas la crise du logement
vous avez beaucoup reproché aux
gouvernements locaux de pas agir dans la
crise le mans vous proposer un registre
des loyers un contrôle des loyers
qu'est-ce que ça va changer par rapport
à la régie du logement d'abord il faut
rendre illégales les hausses abusives de
loyer mécanismes existent en ontario on
veut le répliquer au québec pour
s'assurer que ce soit plus haut le qatar
allait se battre contre vents et marées
face à la régie du logement pour
contester une hausse qui à première vue
abusives faut aussi serré la vis à
airbnb ça s'enlève des logements qui
devraient disponible pour les familles
du québec et à long terme y'a pas 45
solution il faut construire plus de
logements au québec nous avons des
engagements qu'ils ont annoncés très
bientôt mais il faut à terme construire
50 mille logements sociaux au québec il
faut aussi agir sur l'accès à la
propriété on réglera pas je me répète
désolé mais on règlera pro la crise du
coût de la vie sont règle pas la crise
du logement cil premier poste de dépense
de mon ouïe et pour le logement la votre
contrôle des loyers ce qu' il ya eu en
ontario il ya eu en colombie-britannique
également des expériences qui ont été
faites ça a eu un effet pervers parfois
parce que les propriétaires et 20 c'est
les locataires pour essayer de aussi les
loyers est ce que est ce que le régime
veut empêcher ça non mais c'est pour ça
qu'il faut aussi agir contre la
spéculation contre la surenchère on peut
pas seulement contrôler les loyers et
laisser les prix des maisons s'envoler
si on fait ça vous avez bien raison va
avoir un déséquilibre faut faire les
deux agir pour les locataires agir aussi
pour les petits propriétaires et sévir
contre les spéculateurs qui sont en
train de dire de mettre le bordel dans
les villes dans le village du québec oui
vous avez approuvé un programme de
rachat public de maisons expliqué moins
sage mais là vous allez me forcer à
vendre coûteront faire une annonce
demain dans marie victorin avec notre
équipe logement on va rendre disponible
au québec des maisons abordables grâce à
un nouveau fonds anti spéculation
administré par la shq la société
d'habitation du québec on va annoncer
tous les détails demain matin et ça
c'est une mesure elles ont recherché les
maisons plus à l'est ce soir programme
administré par la shq pour ra pour
sortir des maisons de la folie de la
spéculation et réparer la fracture inter
générationnel qui est en train de se
créer au québec parce que là ce qui se
passe c'est sérieux les gens de ma
génération surtout les gens plus jeunes
que moi là sont en train de faire le
deuil de l'accès à la propriété alors
que ça a été la clé pour la qualité de
vie de la génération de nos parents et
nos grands parents moi j'accepte pas
cette fracture intergénérationnel et oui
on va avoir des moyens ambitieux pour
réparer cette fracture salaire minimum
est actuellement à 14h25 voulaient eux
aussi à 18 dollars pensez que c'est
réaliste vraiment à court terme pour les
petits commerces et comme comment les
les pme vont pouvoir payer ça avec tout
ce qui s'est passé pendant la pandémie
ça a été difficile est ce que c'est
possible en ce moment avec le coût du
panier d'épicerie avec le coût de
l'essence avec le coût de tout en fait
de vivre dans la dignité avec le salaire
minimum actuel la réponse est non puis
la preuve c'est quoi ces queues dans les
banques alimentaires aujourd'hui là
c'est plus des gens sur l'aide sociale
qui font la filme ses des travailleurs
et des travailleuses qui travaillent à
temps plein le contrat social du québec
de l'économie québécoise ça devrait être
que si tu travailles à temps plein est
capable d'acheter à manger et en ce
moment on remplit pour ce contrat social
donc à 18 dollars
dubois il ya des gens qui nous regardent
ce soir puis peut-être qu'ils reprennent
contact avec vous ils vous ont connu
comme le leader des carreyrou dans la
rue vous avez été critiqué pour défendre
la désobéissance civile mais toujours
contre la violence sur précisons le il
reste que maintenant vous êtes aspirants
premier ministre dans ce rôle de porte
parole est ce que vous avez fait un bout
de chemin ce que vous avez dû adoucir
vos messages vos positions est-ce que
c'est moins radical qu'en la
mobilisation étudiante a commencé
j'avais 20 ans j'étais tout jeune
j'avais la fougue de mes 20 ans j'avais
aussi le niveau de maturité qui vient
avec dix ans plus tard j'ai pris de la
maturité de la profondeur de
l'expérience vous savez quoi je m'en
cache pas qui ne changent pas dix ans
surtout on devrait et 32 ans donc moi je
suis dans des nouvelles responsabilités
aujourd'hui je vais faire campagne dans
les quatre prochaines semaines j'ai un
projet pour les québécois et québécoises
qu'on devienne un des pays les plus
chers au monde je trouve que c'est un
beau projet j'ai envie de mobiliser les
gens autour de sap ou savez quoi les
gens auront encore quelques semaines
pour me pour apprendre à me connaître et
puis choisiront le 3e ne riez pas le
passé moi ce que j'ai essayé de faire
dans les dix dernières années c'est de
changer sans me trahir je pense que
c'est important d'en vider capable de
dire oui je change mais en même temps
j'ai est fidèle à mes valeurs mes
valeurs ont pas bougé même si ma manière
de faire sans doute ont évolué un peu je
vous rassure vous êtes très jeune
je ne pointais le doigt on va
personnaliser dans le programme de
québec solidaire on peut lire qu'il faut
restreindre le port des armes à feu par
les policiers le jeu site pour les
équiper d'armes à visée non létales bon
ce n'est pas dans votre plateforme
électorale mais est-ce que ça reste un
objectif à long terme que de désarmer
les policiers de la ville de montréal
c'est pourtant de face à nos membres ont
choisi de ne pas le mettre dans notre
plateforme électorale je suis d'accord
avec cette décision là c'est pas dans
les plans de québec solidaire pourquoi
c'est encore dans le programme parce que
y'a plein de pays dans le monde qui ont
fait ce choix là danse danse des dans
des contextes précis en ce moment avec
la crise la violence armée qu'on vit à
montréal c'est pas le temps de faire ça
donc pas de des financements non plus
parce qu' au bout de vos militants qui
milite pour ça ce n'est ni dans la plate
forme et dans le programme de québec
celui d'aÿ et pas question de des
finances et la politique je reprends le
mode anne marie c'est là d'où cissouma
de votre programme là vous avez matures
et à ma connaissance le programme
autorités comme ça en ce moment là notre
priorité ça doit être quoi sadr est de
s'attaquer aux sources de cette violence
armée la agir en prévention mais aussi
libérer les policiers de tâches qui ne
devrait pas leur incombe et quand il ya
un appel sur 3 ou 9 ans qui pour un code
santé mentale que ça veut dire ça tout
le système est monopolisé par des codes
qui en fait devrait parvenir aux
policiers aux policières dont quand on
investit sur le terrain en ressources
communautaires ont des charges les
policiers de ce travail là parce que nos
forces policières c'est quoi leur job
s'attaquer aux criminels s'attaquer au
crime au regard des la soulager de ce
fardeau là pour qu'ils puissent faire
leur travail dernière question sur
l'adoucissement parce que vous proposez
plus la gratuité scolaire du cpe
jusqu'au disque doctorat en cinq ans
comme vous le faisiez aux dernières
élections il ya beaucoup d'étudiants
j'imagine à l'époque aussi qui comptait
beaucoup sur vous donc là encore vous
sentez obligé de faire certains
compromis de vous adapter à la réalité
mais en ce moment la gratuité scolaire
ça existe même pu au primaire et au
secondaire donc gouverner c'est choisir
se présenter devant les québécois c'est
prioriser les choses
la priorité au québec c'est de ramener
une vraie gratuité scolaire au primaire
et au secondaire ceci étant dit on va en
temps mais les réductions des frais de
scolarité parce qu'à long terme c'est
toujours la gratuité qu'on vise mais ça
ça pas grand chose mais mme galipeau de
rendre le cégep ndrc gratuite si ça
coûte des centaines de dollars allait à
l'école primaire et secondaire publique
au québec tranches minces à ponta do
merci beaucoup monsieur nadeau dubois
bienvenue de campagne 50
prochain chef invité paul st pierre
plamondon du parti québécois
on s'est dit oui et ça nous rappelle à
quel point c'est le fun de se dire oui
notwist une façon de dire on repart la
machine
[Musique]
un choix qu'on fait nous nous assumons
pleinement nous sommes un parti dont
l'objectif est de réaliser
l'indépendance du québec on y voit un
intérêt financier on peut pas donner
notre caution morale à quelque chose qui
est trompeur à sa face même ce projet de
loi ne renversera pas le déclin du
français au québec
[Musique]
je crois pas de l'analyse de chiffres
mais juste assez c'est assez clair que
pour l'élection générale dans mary
vecteur il y aura un seul parti qui peut
battre la caq c'est nous l'élection n'a
pas eu lieu et l'élection n'est pas
jouée et nous avons hâte à cette
élection quel avenir pour notre destin
national quel avenir pour la langue
française en amérique
quel avenir pour le titre
paul st pierre plamondon bonjour bonsoir
merci d'être là même question qu'à tous
les chefs menace mépris violence verbale
quelle responsabilité selon vous les
élus ont devant cette dégradation va se
le dire du climat il y en a une c'était
le dixième anniversaire de la prise de
pouvoir dans notre première première
ministre pauline marois mais c'était
également l'anniversaire de l'attentât
je pense que ce qui sous notre contrôle
comme politicien c'est devenu une
politique qui parle d'avenir kuni lige
et qui fait qu'ils créent de l'intérêt
parce que non seulement de l'enjeu de la
sécurité mais regardez ce qui s'est
passé en ontario lors des dernières
élections un taux de participation de
43% c'est la démocratie occidentale qui
est en jeu en ce moment et moi ce que je
contrôle c'est d'abord une campagne
positive la plus sympathique et on est
possible en espérant qu'on intéresse des
gens à la démocratie qu on les incite à
voter dans la paix et le respect donc
vous vous n'avez pas pointé du doigt par
exemple monsieur duhaime comme d'autres
ont fait non vous avez vu mais je me
tasse de ses activités de pointage de
doigts et je ramène à des propositions
structurants pour l'avenir en espérant
susciter l'intérêt vous êtes le seul à
ne pas proposer ni baisses d'impôts dont
québec solidaire n'a pas de baisses
d'impôts mais eux ils ont des baisses de
taxes de la tvq ni baisse de taxes dans
votre camp ce que donnent les autres
partis ce que vont redonner les autres
partis aux québécois est ce que vous
vous allait réinvestir ça ça dépend de
l'éducation pour le même montant pour
moi vous ne ferez pas de pause fisc
parce que c'est irresponsable
évidemment l'or en temps d'inflation on
a fait un raisonnement simple au parti
québécois il ya un trop perçu par l'état
d'environ 6 milliards mon vol prendre on
va leur donner aux familles qui ont des
moeurs a rejoint des dieux bout ça veut
dire à peu près 1200 $ par famille 750
pour certaines d'entre elles mais on
vise ceux qui gagnent entre 0 et 80 ml
par personne mais ouais je veux pas
donner comme québec solidaire une baisse
de taxes qui avantage les plus riches ou
pire des baisses d'impôts cas qui donne
des cadeaux aux plus riches mais qui par
surcroît attaque directement nos
services publics
un aller simple vers l'austérité et pour
tous les travailleurs qui en ont
souffert la dernière fois de l'austérité
je leur dis n'encouragez pas les partis
qui vont attaquer les services publics
en réduisant notre assiette fiscale pour
nos services à tout le monde dans notre
société donc ça sera une fois une seule
fois 1200 pour ceux qui gagnent 50 mais
les moins 750 pour ce jusqu'à 80 milles
c'est tout on soir puis en outre 80
mairie a pas de cadeau on est tous ceux
qui en ont besoin puis il n'y a pas de
conséquences à long terme
c'est pas à vous que je vais apprendre
que le combat entre les souverainistes
et les fans et les fédéralistes ne
définit plus la joute politique où on ne
leur effectuer des fois ce nombre si on
nous le répète pas dans le but de
choisir ce qu'il voit le nouveau palace
non mais c'est est omniprésent dans les
campagnes au québec depuis soit 1970 je
vous entends temps qu'on en parle moins
vous entendre là dessus
québec solidaire il le dit tout à
l'heure promet même un référendum dans
un premier temps sur une constitution
sur une constitution
le lac ac s'est emparé du discours
nationaliste il vous reste coi au pq
l'indépendance du québec un projet de
société qu'on assume pleinement
françois legault a pris le pouvoir en
2018 en disant aux québécoises et aux
québécois
regardez moi bien moi je vais faire des
gros gains dans le canada il frappe pour
0 en 21 tous ceux qui connaissent un peu
le baseball spawn moyenne digne des
ligues majeures
mais ce chose c'est sur des questions
fondamentales il manque 6 milliards dans
notre système de santé on envoie nos
impôts pour financier les pétrolières de
l'alberta mais à coût de 2 milliards
d'argent québécois imaginez si on
prenait cet argent là et on investit
dans nos compagnies pour la nouvelle
économie verte et sur des questions
fondamentales comme l'application des
lois environnementales sur notre
territoire l'application de la loi 101
partout sur notre territoire notamment
aux entreprises à charte fédérale
je pose la question pourquoi est ce
qu'on n'aurait pas le droit comme tout
peuple normal de décider par nous mêmes
et c'est avec fierté que je porte un
projet de société qui est inspirant et
qu'irréaliste celui d'être un pays qui
règne partout dans le monde donc votre
mission je les ai presque la seule
marque à votre mission principale c'est
d'aller chercher les 30 33 % de gens qui
se disent encore souveraineté mais on
les voit pas encore chez vous pour quoi
bon aller votre plus en plus il ya une
transformation c'est un discours assumé
aussi qu'on a du fun
et dont seulement il ya 2 millions et
plus d'indépendantistes mais combien de
millions de personnes au québec en ce
moment se préoccupe de l'avenir du
français nous sommes le seul parti
politique à dire que la loi 96 elle est
insuffisante et tous les experts
confirment notre position et nous sommes
le seul parti à vouloir renverser ce
déclin de la même manière que de manière
inexplicable à mes yeux nous sommes le
seul parti à avoir un plan pour assurer
la dignité de nos aînés et on parlait
des baisses d'impôts et de taxes ont
encore une fois très distinctif donc on
va mener une campagne d'idées qui
démontrent que le parti québécois donne
l'heure juste vis juste sur plusieurs
enjeux qui intéresse la population en
2017 chef de votre parti jean françois
lisée pour ne pas le nommer avait
envisagé une alliance stratégique ce
n'est pas une union mais c'est une
alliance stratégique avec q s puis on a
su bon ça peut fonctionner que tu as a
racheté que c
est ce qu on pourrait imaginer dans
votre esprit l'union avec québec
solidaire qui se dit je le répète
résolument souverainiste
bien honnêtement moi je mène campagne
vis-à-vis une cac qui sur les éléments
fondamentaux qui nous inspire ne livre
pas du tout la marchandise ou pire ne
s'occupe pas n'a pas d'intérêt pour ces
sujets ensuite il ya bien d'autres
partis politiques mais je pense que
c'est pas en cachant ses idées ou en
faisant toute sorte de compromis qu'on
inspire les gens
le pari que j'ai pris que nos candidates
et nos candidats ont pris avons prises
c'est de dire on va assumer pleinement
nos idées parler ouvertement de nos
idéaux et inspirer les gens avec les
propositions les plus intelligente
possible et on verra comment nos
religions nous répondre est ce que vous
êtes revenu de ce choc là quand même ou
quand on s'est parlé la dernière fois au
printemps de voir des bernard de rêve
caroline st-hilaire des souverainistes
qui ont milité aux côtés de vos su
qu'ils étaient avant vos parti québécois
allaient à la casse cous est dit là
vraiment je suis pas la bonne période
pour moi pour être chef
et chef du parti québécois c'est un
contrôle je disais ça vient avec sa part
de soubresauts et de houle une fois que
ces dits par contre moi je constate que
la caq a échoué dans son fédéralisme et
contraint des candidats a même pas être
capable de nommer leurs convictions à
cacher ce qu'il pense vraiment au parti
québécois vous trouverez que des
candidates et des candidats qui peuvent
vous regarder dans les yeux et dit moi
je tends politique pour ça je te tends
tic je suis le pour les bonnes raisons
et moi je pense que ça une valeur
politique surtout en ce moment où est ce
que on en parle un peu mais il a un
frein énorme landes espace du positif et
des gens qui sont là par conviction avec
des inspirations sincère je pense ça va
faire du bien vous êtes on va peut-être
on va peut-être même mourir vaut mourir
debout
non je dis on est debout puis les gens
qui sont debout sont récompensés
généralement être persévérant être droit
d'ailleurs pauline marois est un exemple
éloquent parce qu'elle aurait pu choisir
de consentir à l'intimidation et à la
part et parce qu'elle est demeuré debout
mais elle a accompli de belles choses
par la suite même principe et sa date
depuis les patriotes nous sommes un
peuple qui est capable de se tenir
debout puis qui a enduré et qui mérite
un jour d'être dans la normalité
c'est-à-dire pas être dans les sécurité
constante sur le plan culturel et
linguistique que nous impose le canada
est un régime qui complètement dépassés
pour des raisons environnementales
également alors vous misez depuis début
de cette campagne sur l'indépendance
l'urgence linguistique déclin du
français est ce que c'est vraiment ce
qui préoccupe le plus les gens en ce
moment
peut-être pas mais parlons en de ces
mesures vous voulez imposer la loi 101
au cégep pour défendre le français mais
en commet en quoi ça empêcherait le
déclin du français
dont nous consulter des experts ils
disent que la loi 96 ne renversera pas
le déclin mais il propose également des
mesures structurantes j'insiste pour
dire qu'on peut proposer des mesures
pour le français qui en étaient très
pertinents sur l'environnement le coût
de la vie les ennemis les cpe ce qu'on
fait mais le français demeure une
question fondamentale c'est notre droit
d'exister et le cégep est une mesure qui
ont une influence sur le milieu de
travail par après parce qu on socialise
dans la langue nationale et rappelons
que partout en europe en amérique latine
partout dans le monde normalement
l'éducation pré universal prix
universitaires pardon elle se passe dans
la langue nationale donc ce ne serait
pas
rien de
négatif et rappelons également que les
anglophones ne se voit toujours dans ce
qu'on propose garantit leur place mary
franco fruits en anglais francophones
qui voudrait étudier en fera en anglais
dans un cégep anglophone est ce que
voulait pénaliser pas
les études démontrent qu'en fait ce chef
n'est pas un lieu d'apprentissage de
l'anglais les francophones et les
allophones qui vont au cégep en anglais
le maîtrise déjà mais ça démontre que
c'est un lieu de socialisation en
anglais qui est france fortement les
comportements en milieu de travail c'est
une mesure parmi plusieurs donc il faut
voir l'ensemble de ce qu'on propose mais
on on refuse d'être les climato
sceptiques de la langue iyer déclin il
est marqué accéléré on consulte des
experts qui nous arrive avec des mesures
structurantes que malheureusement la cac
n'a pas eu le courage et le sens des
responsabilités
d'appliquer ça fait donc de nous le seul
parti à la défense du français en ce
moment mais c'est pas une tare de
vouloir étudier en anglais aussi j'ai
pour un francophone va pas perdre sa
langue en allant en attendant qu'est ce
que vous visez plus les allophones alors
oui c'est surtout les allophones parce
que quand on essaie de comprendre
pourquoi la langue décline c'est
vraiment essentiellement le transfert
linguistique des allophones qui à 45 %
utiliseront à la fin il en anglais comme
langue de tous les jours et nous on vise
à ce que ce soit beaucoup plus élevé
parce que le le niveau de pérennité de
la langue faudrait que ce soit 90%
proxim hâtivement de transfert vers le
français on n'est pas là du tout donc
c'est pour ça que ça prend des mesures
fortes et ça prend des mesures le plus
étrange de la loi caquistes c'est qu'on
se refuse à mesurer l'évolution du
français on se donne même possible même
chose en environnement d'ailleurs il ya
un plan vert qui de l'avis de tous les
experts est insuffisant et on se refuse
à mesurer même léger us c'est pas
sérieux et pourtant c'est des questions
qui nous tiennent à coeur à juste titre
empêcher les entreprises d'exiger le
bilinguisme à l'embauché est ce que
c'est vraiment faisable est ce que c'est
vraiment souhaitable même oui je prenons
à gatineau l'a encore récemment donc la
ville embauche pour des postes
spécifiques en financer leur demande de
un caractère bilingue et globalement ce
convoi sic l'exigence du bilinguisme
s'est imposé pour toutes sortes
d'emplois qui n'ont rien à voir avec
l'anglais et mettez vous dans la peau de
gens qui ont choisi de vivre au québec
qui sont unilingues francophones qui
choisissent le québec parce que c'est
une terre francophone et qui se voit
discriminé à l'emploi parce qu'ils ne
parlent pas anglais la bilinguisation
des milieux de travail entraîne à terme
on le voit dans la fonction publique
canadienne notamment ses entraînements
en anglais comme langue commune dont il
les séries de la loi 101 c'est toujours
que la langue de fonctionnement soit le
français donc pour la grande majorité
des emplois fonctionner en france est
simple et que t'as pas besoin de
maîtrise parfaite de l'anglais pour
faire un post en finance ou un poste de
commis administratif veut pas tout les
nommer mais il ya vraiment là dessus
quelque chose à faire parmi plusieurs
mesures sont dans une ville comme
montréal quand même il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises qui vont conquérir des
marchés internationaux et quand même
parler la langue d'affaires oui puis je
dis pas que tous les emplois le but
c'est pas de nuire aux entreprises mais
se décrit l'environnement qui est le
plus propice à maintenir le français
comme langue commune est en ce moment à
montréal on voit quelqu'un glisse mme
faut réagir de manière proportionnelle
et intelligente sans nuire pour autant
d'entreprises se poursuit d'ailleurs
j'ai dit première chose que je vais
faire je vais m'asseoir avec les
entreprises pour comprendre le où on
peut faciliter allégé mais je matin les
entreprises malheureusement avec les pdg
plus français des fois c'est pas
toujours gagnant mais je m'attendais
entreprises à de la bonne foi et a du
respect du québec
l'enjeu il est là les québécois ont
droit au respect et le fédéralisme à
plat ventre east de la caq depuis quatre
ans ne nous a pas donné ce respect là ça
donne des situations comme air canada
mais ça donne des refus inexplicable
comme les 6 milliards de dollars en
santé qui nous manque toujours donc je
pense que de se tenir debout ne ferait
pas de tort dans les circonstances et
pas un certain repli de soi on peut
créer une cale en un point empêchant le
bilinguisme ma vision du québec en est
un qui est indépendant qui rayonne
partout dans le monde où on gagne le
championnat du monde de hockey puis à
l'onu on est comme un peu la norvège et
la suède pour une influence positivement
déconfit moi c'est ça ma vision du
québec il y en a pas de repli il ya le
rayonnement dans notre droit d'exister
mais ça fait depuis les patriotes qu'on
se demande si on a le droit d'exister
moi j'aimerais ce con qu'on aboutisse à
un moment donné dans quelque chose de
pouce une immigration économique 100%
francophone également ça avec lui tous
les problèmes de pénurie de main
d'oeuvre est ce que ça risque pas de
nuire on le vit en angleterre en
hollande dans plusieurs pays européens
ça se passe bien rappelons par contre
qu'on est ouvert parce que des fois il
ya des emplois avec une compétence très
spécifique la personne ne parle pas le
français on y trouvèrent à financer des
cours avant l'arrivée on it were à des
ententes spécifiques mais en général et
d'ailleurs votre collègue grand méchoui
relevé que françois legault n'a pas dit
toute la vérité tantôt le quand il se
vantait d'avoir 80 % l'immigration
francophone il prend la dernière année
où en cause de la pandémie les chefs est
altérée mais la réalité est tout autre
et est vraiment l'immigration la
maîtrise du français au niveau de
l'immigration change beaucoup la donne
donc j'aurai l'occasion pendant la
campagne de parle parler d'un autre
modèle au niveau de l'immigration qui
donnera une durabilité aux français tout
en s'assurant du succès le pour tout le
monde rapidement est ce que vous comptez
réduire les seuils d'immigration vous
maintenez les cinq ans plaît je vais
réduire on va proposer de réduire les
seuils d'immigration mais c'est pas la
seule composante qu'on revoie c'est le
modèle au complet de manière à ce que
tant au niveau des seuils au niveau de
la régionalisation
réduire les ressources
dans fait une annonce demain matin donc
clos
donnez moi
demain matin je l'annoncerai je vais pas
rentrer le siège nex 5 ans et moins de
50 milles mais je veux qu'on retienne
que c'est pas que les seuils et que on
peut réussir un modèle différent de
celui du canada qui nous garantiront
spirit et linguistique culturelle iphone
qui dit mieux j'en parle demain puis je
veux le présenter manière complète et un
sujet qui plus délicat et ma
responsabilité c'est d'en traiter avec
responsabilité dans l'intérêt de tous
les québécois d'adoption parce que près
- l'identité québécoise 5 lui tout le
monde je souhaite vraiment que tous les
québécois se sentent québécois à part
entière
paul st pierre plamondon
maison des aînés annonce importante 3
milliards par année pour les soins à
domicile
recommandations faites par plusieurs
experts sur ce sujet mais monsieur
legault nous disait tout à l'heure c'est
irréaliste de la pole on n'a pas les
infirmières l'apport personnel donc
c'est une promesse d irréaliste s'est
basé sur les meilleures pratiques
notamment celle du danemark le modèle ou
est ce que on mise sur le béton il est
financièrement non viable non seulement
pas ça coûte cher 1 million par champ
mais c'est parce que dans ensuite dans
le fonctionnement ça nous mène droit
dans un mur ça coûterait 75 milliards
construire une maison des aînés pour
tout le monde qui en ont besoin ça ne
marche pas quand on regarde certains
pays européens qui ont réussi ce sont
les mêmes soins donc mais au lieu de les
faire dans l'hôpital ou dans des
institutions on change l'endroit et on
amène désir des entreprises d'économie
sociale et des gens qui sont civiles
donc peut-être qu'ils sont pas formés
comme médecin mais qui vont donner du
soutien et des soins donc on augmente le
nombre de personnes capables de
s'occuper de nos aînés et ça ça fait
partie de la solution parce que dans un
système hospitalo centristes ou c'est
surtout l'acte du médecin qui compte il
ya un nombre limité de médecins ça coûte
cher puis à la fin mai lire les services
sont pas au rendez vous donc on veut
augmenter le nombre de personnes qui
s'occupent de nos aînés et réduire le
coût par intervention en mettant à
profit toutes les professions toutes les
profils de personnes qui ont à coeur la
dignité des années quand faut il avoir
toutes ces professions tout ce personnel
pour lancer soins domicile à plus de
45000 personnes là qui sont en attente
oui vraiment mais c'est la direction
qu'il faut prendre parce que ne pas agir
est demeuré le cadre des soins à
domicile donc quand on regarde les
ratios là on est vraiment à la traîne
c'est financièrement
très dangereux on veut frapper un mur
inspirons-nous des meilleures pratiques
dans le monde et voyons comment on peut
progresser la science le changement
climatique on n'allait pas me parler pas
mal ce soir mais une mesure que vous
proposez qui est celle d'interdire la
vente de tous les sens dès 2030 et aussi
forcé les concessionnaires à vendre 50%
de voiture électrique assez rapidement
oui comment on arrive à ça mais qu'est
ce que ça change mais premièrement
j'aimerais rappeler qu'on a un plan
solide et complet le hasard a fait
également qu'on a fait appel à la même
firme internationale que pour le plan de
québec solidaire donc énormément de
solides de similarités
fusionner mais la différence près que la
castration
à quelques différences près témoin
l'approché différente québec solidaire
dit on va pénaliser ceux qui achètent
une voiture à gaz à partir de 2023 nous
on regarde ce qu'ils ont dit a tant dit
commençons par donner des options
consommateurs et ce qu'en ce moment il
ya une option pour acheter un véhicule
électrique non donc on a mis des mesures
de contrainte sur le constructeur pour
l'y forcer comme en suède en allemagne
avant une livre véhicules électriques
qui ont dit on va doubler l'offre de
transport collectif avec une passe
l'humain lorsqu'on aura fait ce nous on
sera à l'aise peut-être de mettre un
malus des pénalités mais je ne vois pas
comment ça va être productif de taxer
des gens dès 2023 qu'ils % de plus sur
un véhicule alors qu'ils n'ont pas
d'options c'est pénaliser les gens alors
qu c contre leurs grilles on leur donne
pas de solution nous on veut que ce soit
gagnant-gagnant on veut par là des gens
qui n'ont pas voté peut-être par le
passé en fonction de l'environnement et
on leur dit
tous ensemble on peut prendre une autre
direction qui va être payante pour le
québec parce qu'on a un potentiel au
niveau de l'économie verte qui est
exceptionnel notre pays est sécurisé ou
punir les gens lorsque c'est
contre-productif pas à terre d'un monde
dont vous avez fait le saut en politique
si vous êtes jeune orphelin politique
vous vous parti de gauche modérée
progressiste vous êtes à la tête du
parti québécois à un moment extrêmement
difficile et vous avez là c'est votre
campagne vous avez fait pour le pq c'est
un vote pour l'espoir mais au fond
est-ce que c'est l'élection la dernière
chance pour le pq on sait justement
l'élection de l'espoir il ya la cac qui
nous invite à la résignation quant à
notre avenir national mais quand tu as
des questions fondamentales comme
l'environnement une français parce que
ya pas de volonté d'agir puis à nous qui
arrivent avec des choses bien ficelé
irréfléchie et s'est livré avec toute
l'authenticité que ça mérite puis moi je
vais m'en remettre aux électeurs tout
simplement donc je pense que lorsqu'on a
le choix entre la résignation et
l'espoir ont choisi l'espoir mais je
pense surtout parce que la caq parle
tout le temps de fierté la fierté s'est
pas caché ses convictions puis la fierté
c'est pas de renoncer la fierté c'est de
se tenir debout dire moi j'en pense sur
ça c'est ce que je pense plus dire aux
électeurs moi c'est ça c'est clair à
vous de faire votre opinion mais la
fierté c'est des gens qui parlent de
leurs convictions avec droiture dans
ceux qui ont joué la caq confort que
vous savez être souverainiste n'ont pas
grand monde ce soir ont perdu tout de
fierté je me garde vraiment dans cette
campagne de faire des attaques aux
autres partis je maintiens ce que
j'espère que nous avons réalisés puis on
a du plaisir à le faire peut-être que
l'indépendance les gens et en rêvent
mais n'y croient plus aux pieds toutes
nuances peut-être mais laissez moi au
moins les inspirer vous aviez un avenir
qui serait pas mal plus le fun moi je
pense que ce serait le plus beau moment
de politique de notre vie le jour où met
au monde un pays ce plongeon en
politique
ce que le jeu en valait la chandelle moi
je me trouve privilégie privilégie de
faire de la politique en disant
exactement ce que j'en pense privilégiée
de faire de la politique dans une
formation qui a une longue tradition
depuis rené lévesque évidemment de
bienveillance envers la population
québécoise puis je me dis bien si c'est
des valeurs une façon de concevoir la
politique qui est vraiment importante
donc je content d'être là a terminé je
suis la campagne est ce que ces déportés
comme assez lourd à porter quand même
super
la politique je pense pour tous ceux qui
ont défilé avant moi elle est exigeante
pas plus pour moi mais moi je me trouve
qu'il privilégie de faire ce que je fais
merci pas un terreau permanent mais
bonne fin de campagne justement merci
d'être venu nous voir un vrai plaisir
merci prochain chef invité éric duhaime
du parti conservateur du québec
aujourd'hui j'ai la conviction profonde
que chez la bonne personne au bon
endroit au bon moment
[Musique]
on veut respecter les libertés de chacun
plutôt qu'un gouvernement qui nous
impose ses choix on veut que ce soient
les choix des québécois les choix de
chaque citoyen que soient respectées les
talents de la chanson seront davantage
mises à contribution
la voix du parti conservateur du québec
se fera davantage entendent à partir
d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
mon arme ans et plusieurs milliers
dizaines de milliers de signatures
contre le passeport vaccinale
obligatoire si comme nous vous croyez
qu'il est temps de mettre fin à l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
perpétuelle mais vous devez voter pour
le parti conservateur du québec pour
nous troisième ligne c'est non
négociable
ça fait tellement d'années qu'on en
parle c'est une nécessité de la région
de québec il ya un an on était à 1 %
dans les sondages aujourd'hui
dépendamment de quelle firme vous voyez
on est à 13 15 19 il nous reste 43 de
dos pas à monter c'est encore plus
[Applaudissements]
monsieur duhaime bonsoir bonsoir on a
parlé avec chacun des chefs du climat
politique actuel donc vous est ce que
vous êtes d'accord pour dire d'abord que
le climat politique s'est détériorée
et puis j'ai fait un appel au calme
comme vous savez à trois reprises au
cours pendant trois jours consécutifs je
pense que c'est important comme chef
politique de le faire la politique
parfois c'est un sport où il ya eu ça
brasse un peu mais on a un devoir ont
une responsabilité effectivement quand
ça dérape quand il ya des gens qui se
font menacer d'intervenir puis 10,2
d'appeler tout le monde au calme vous
parlez de responsabilité mais est ce que
votre discours par exemple sur les
mesures sanitaires quand vous parlez de
libertis et quand vous parlez de jean
sacrifiés est-ce que ça ça a pas
nourries la colère est donc alimenté ce
climat était au québec présentement il
ya une insatisfaction vieux un
mécontentement les droits devant
l'endroit du gouvernement puis
évidemment que tout ce qui s'est passé
au cours des deux dernières années il ya
contribué moi je me fais le la voix de
celles et ceux qui sont présentement
mécontents qui sont insatisfaits de ce
que le gouvernement fait et je pense que
c'est tout à fait démocratique c5
justement que cette voie là se fassent
entendre jusqu'à l'assemblée nationale
c'est ça la démocratie
c'était c'est justement de prendre cette
mécontentement le jeu même utilisé le
mot grogne pour faire entrer sa
l'assemblée nationale afin que ces gens
là puissent avoir une voix autour de la
table où les décisions se prennent ces
seuls avait dans une société
démocratique ce qui serait pas ce qu il
serait malsain ce serait que ces voix là
soit à l'extérieur est manifeste et qui
ne se retrouvent pas autour de la table
parce qu'il y avait eu un unanimisme un
peu assourdissant l'assemblée nationale
pendant plusieurs mois
et ces gens là ne se faisaient pas
entendre nous ne justement que la
démocratie soit un petit peu plus
représentatif qu'il y ait eu cette
déficit démocratique là mais il ya quand
même 50 % de vos électeurs qui sont plus
ou moins complotistes l'on pense à des
gens qui se lancer une étude de la
chaire unesco mais à des gens qui
pensent que bill gates a créé la
pandémie que dans la lch n'a pas gagné
l'élection donc est-ce que vous sans les
cautionner est-ce que vous jouez pas
quand même un peu là dessus parce que
vous savez c'est quoi le pourcentage de
complotiste selon cette étude le parti
libéral et au parti québécois c'est 30 %
juste vous dire que l'on n'a pas le
monopole
même la cac il y aura 15 % des jeunes en
hausse indiquent que la cohésion vers
québec de françois legault qui seraient
des complices est ce que cette question
devrait être posée à monsieur legault à
monsieur plamondon ou à madame anglade
non quand même des gens comme anne
casabonne qui dit par exemple les
vaccins se lasser de la mort de jr et
faisait part aussi vous savez de pierre
falardeau elle répétait un rôle qu'elle
avait déjà joué dans un de ses films
puis ça a été ça a été monté en épingle
mais moins le je pense que ultime ans la
position du parti conservateur sur cette
enveloppe est une question très
importante
puis c'est pas parceque une christine
tard j'ai toujours été quelqu'un qui
était que défendent les libertés
individuelles et les droits civiques et
pour moi quelqu'un qui se fait injecter
quelque chose dans son corps c'est une
question de liberté de choix et j'ai eu
l'impression que comme plusieurs
citoyens au québec que cette liberté-là
été brimés au cours des derniers mois et
moi je me suis porté à la défense de
celles et ceux qui pensent que c'est un
choix individuel et personnel comprend
cette décision le quand on consulte
notre médecin mais que l'on ne pourra se
faire imposer cette décision ça veut
dire qu'au nom de la liberté et des
libertés et des droits aucune mesure
pour vous ne s'imposeraient même devant
une
nouvelle pandémie aussi grave que celle
qu'on a des postes que j'ai dit l'on
parlait spécifiquement madame tussauds
de la vaccination
évidemment qu'il peut y avoir des
mesures mais quand il ya des mesures
sanitaires qui sont imposées comme élu
vous avez le devoir de faire la balance
aussi entre les effets pervers que ça
peut avoir aussi que sur les enfants y
voir des effets pendant une génération
sur la sédentarité sur les faillites de
commerce sur la santé mentale de
plusieurs personnes il faut faire la
balance et le problème qu'ont eue au
québec c'est que pendant des mois on a
une espèce d'amalgamé entre l'ès à 3
santé publique et le politique on ne
savait plus qu est ce qui est est
identique de ce qui était politique et
malheureusement sa axa a créé un climat
qui était une très malsain on a une qui
cellule de crise que gérer cette crise
là où il y avait un seul scientifique il
y avait quinze personnes autour de la
table qui étaient des apparatchiks
politiques ou des gens non l'intérêt
c'est de faire réélire françois legault
donc on ne vit qu'une rumeur situation
qui était très problématique faut le
reconnaître mais vous parler davantage
des sacrifiés de la pandémie vous venez
de les décrire l'homme et certains
effets pervers parce que leur liberté a
été restreint mais on vous entend jamais
parler
des vies qui ont été sauvées grâce à des
mesures sanitaires jamais on vous entend
parler de ces gens agréables souvent
fait du surf sur l'autre dans celle le
québec que vous avez vous conviendrez
avec moi était l'endroit on a mis tant
au canada qu il ait mesure s'installer
plus strictes pourtant on ne le bilan
père capital le plus mauvais ce les
mesures étaient steve antastique avait
sauver autant de vies australie mayard
paul et dernier dont casas vous
contredis là dessus mais la science ne
contredit pas madame une souche je cite
des chiffres le jeu après je voulais
texter après l'émission il ya plus de
morts par capitaux au québec en raison
de la copie depuis on a eu des mesures
simples beaucoup plus sévère donc si les
mesures centa fonctionne
extraordinairement bien on aura un
meilleur bilan faire le lien entre les
deux c'est post évident que et le
gouvernement au manque et c'est surtout
au niveau de la première vague j'ai eu
des choses qui ont été faites qui ont
pas été correct vous savez comme moi que
6000 personnes qui sont mortes dans des
serres chez celles des vous savez comme
moi qu'il ya eu des transferts entre les
hôpitaux et les résidences personnes
âgées ou les sécher celle des lieux lui
un paquet problème au québec et on
refuse encore à ce jour d'avoir une
enquête publique indépendante pour faire
la lumière pour pouvoir comprendre
comment ça se fait que ces 6000
personnes sont décédées il va falloir un
jour qu'on fasse ici parce conservatoire
est porté au pouvoir le 4 octobre peut
être sur hull 4 octobre au matin on va
commencer mais pour reprendre sur la
même ligne d'une seconde avant de vous
parler des baisses d'impôts ville
d'autre chose que de seul on va regarder
en avant mais quand même la surmortalité
les derniers chiffres qui sont sortis
donnait raison monsieur legault ça a été
moins pire au québec mais au-delà de ça
est ce que vous parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de vos partisans qui ne croyaient pas au
vaccin c'est leur droit de ne pas croire
au vaccin mais ce n'est pas la
responsabilité à manier d'un
gouvernement de dire mais pour aller
dans un autobus pour dans un avion ça va
prendre un passeport vaccinale pour
protéger les jaunes et oui on aime
poster restreint les libertés mais mardi
c'est nécessaire écoutez le les gens qui
comme moi est doublement vacciner au
triplement avec ses mains ils peuvent là
ils peuvent quand même avoir la cobi
peuvent quand même la transmettre
c'était pas le vaccin n'était possible
si la connerie paix avant ceux des
volumes sur moi si et seulement si on
avait la certitude que les gens vaccinés
ne le transmettent pas une la trappe
mais c'est pas ce qui est arrivé et puis
souvent toutes ces mesures on a souvent
l'impression que c'était par beaucoup
par vengeance monsieur legault il a été
un rappelez vous le disais qu'ils
voulaient même pas se faire traiter par
une infirmière non vaccinés un certain
moment puis aujourd'hui le redis même si
vous avez envie d'aller travailler on
aime beaucoup de contradictions de la
part de ce gouvernement dans ce dossier
lui et lui la science change sauf que la
science quand il ya un consensus pour un
chef de gouvernement c'est mieux suivre
la science que l'installation ça a été
suivi j'attends encore la première étude
pour savoir que c'est quoi l'impact du
couvre-feu c'est quoi et où l'étude
scientifique là dessus comment s'assurer
que monsieur roudeina a pris en
commission parlementaire qu'il n'y avait
jamais recommandé la fermeture des
salles à manger alors monsieur legault
nous avait dit qu'elle était sa bête une
recommandation scientifique il faudrait
faire la lumière qui aurait fallu
séparer la science du politique et
s'apprêter fait eu un amalgame au québec
et est très malsain monsieur duhaime
vous proposer les plus généreuses
baisses d'impôts de tous les chefs qu'on
a vu ce soir je pense que ces 25
milliards sur quatre ans si j'ai bien
compté on va en voir
antenne de cartes finance
ça peut te ben ça dépend sur combien
d'années vous dire 4 c'est ça pour les
financiers vous dire je vais couper dans
le gras qu'elle gras ou legrand est-ce
que c'est austérité fois mais il ya 3 il
ya trois sources de revenus d'abord on
veut comme vous savez exploiter nos
hydrocarbures on veut augmenter les
revenus on veut pas juste diminuer les
dépenses on veut augmenter les revenus
du gouvernement en exploitant nos
hydrocarbures de façon responsable au
québec deuxièmement on n'est pas des
partis sont les des conservateurs
fiscaux on ne veut pas distribué de 10
millions des centaines de millions des
milliards à des multinationales comme le
ministre d'économie piaffer tribune le
fait beaucoup ont vu réduire
considérablement les subventions aux
grandes entreprises et oui on veut
dégraisser aussi la machine de l'état ya
du gras qu'on veut réduire on veut
réduire la taille de l'état ça fait
partie de nos trois priorités seront
jeumont on va tous on voit tout cas le
cadre financier va être présentée je
vous demanderais d'être un peu patient
mais mais on veut on veut quand même pas
malade sur première mais on veut quand
même on veut car même réduire parce
qu'on considère que c'est aux québécois
le les québécois ont besoin d'avoir un
jpy en cette période d'inflationniste
c'était au gouvernement de serrer la
ceinture pour familles du québec vous
parlez de relancer les hydrocarbures
promettait donc des milliards de revenus
et pourtant on sait pas on sait même pas
si en a assez pour ce soit rentable de
les exploiter au québec que ya plusieurs
projets le d'abord il ya ce premier on
le sait que des entreprises qui avaient
déjà des droits qui on est en train de
lorgner d'ordre web présentement il est
poursuivi pour des milliards ou on
risque d de les québécois risquent de
payer parce qu'ils n'exploitent pas leur
ressource est quand même assez paradoxal
on a un projet de gnl québécois dans la
région de saguenay que j'ai visité il ya
quelques jours où on est un
investissement de 14 milliards que le
gouvernement avait dit oui initialement
et auquel il vient de dire non depuis un
an
si on avait fait ça vous savez comme moi
vous savez comme moi madame galipeau que
sont habitées de l'avant aujourd'hui
entre peut-être venir en aide à nos
partenaires européens particulièrement
allemand une délégation allemande qui
s'est amené au pays ont récemment la
semaine dernière parce que ces gens là
ont besoin justement de gaz naturel
liquéfié pour passer au travers du var
chauffer les foyers en allemagne et
malheureusement classique maintenant si
on avait commencé quand on n'est qu'en
grec a été élu s'il avait suivi sa
propre promesse aujourd'hui on pourrait
aider les allemands plutôt qu'à des
parts un passif qui les regardent est
obligé de retourner au charbon avec des
technologies beaucoup plus polluante
vous croyez aux hydrocarbures oui je
crois bien ce à dire que les
hydrocarbures peuvent être une source
aussi de revenus pour électrifier les
transports pour permettre la transition
vous savez la norvège est le pays qui
exportent exploiter le plus ces
hydrocarbures pour payer justement son
électrification ces transports qui
aujourd'hui c'est le pays qui fait le
mieux placé en termes plus en ces termes
là le rappelez vous que monsieur legault
lui manque pour moi qui disais que dans
son propre livre il disait qu'il à faire
du québec une norvège d'amérique il
voulait il voulait faire comme eux et
aujourd'hui il vient d'adopter un projet
de loi pour interdire des hydrocarbures
ce nom promesses rompues monsieur
legault ne faut pas l'oublier bon vous
avez aucun plan aucune cible de
réduction des gaz à effet de serre
comment c'est possible en 2002 pour un
parti mais comment c'est possible qu'il
y ait quatre partisans avant moi qui
soit venu ici vous présenter des signes
qu'il ya quelqu'un qui puisse les croire
tous les gouvernements de tous les
partis s'ils nous ont toujours promis
des baisses de si jamais il y en a un
qui atteint ses cibles moi je m'excuse
mais quand j'entends des policiers me
dire ce soit le sait quoi 40 50 55 % de
baisse de 2,2 gs c'est parce que
qu'est-ce que vous allez coupé combien
d'entreprises vous allez fermer et à
combien de personnes à l'empêcher de
conduire leur véhicule combien de gens
pourront plus faire de ski doo de
moteurs de motos ou de gauche avoir un
bateau c'est beau c'est facile de lancer
des chiffres et la deuxième chose pour
il faut arrêter de regarder des traits
québec centrisme l'émission si vous
regardez ce sera une échelle planétaire
si par exemple on allait de l'avant en
exploitant nos hydrocarbures ce qu'on
fait on permettait justement de
remplacer le charbon par du gaz naturel
québécois onfray réduire les gaz à effet
de serre à l'échelle planétaire mais on
met au québec ça pourrait effectivement
stagné mais mais ces jeux vous faut le
regarder dans son ensemble pour arrêter
de juste pensé au québec.le parce qu'on
veut pas le but c'est pas d'exporter la
pollution et de délocaliser la pollution
est ce que vous pouvez réussir deux
changements à l'échelle de royer crise
dans notre programme et
il faut faire quelque chose puis le
québec peut être un partenaire pi je
sais que cela semble paradoxal mais
l'exploitation de nos ressources
peut être une façon effectivement
d'aider d'autres pays à améliorer leur
bilan rhône mental mais la liberté qui
est votre dogme et d'une certaine
manière c'est bien des brushings vous
empêche tel
style d'imposer des sacrifices des
changements de mode de vie aux citoyens
parce que c'est ça que dans le monde
entier on dit la planète se meurt on
regarde les dessins épouvantable
catastrophe naturelle mais faut changer
nous aussi notre comportement est en
chemin vous qu'il faut sensibiliser la
population rien contre elle mais la
contrainte parce que il ya des
contraintes qui ont des effets pervers
c'est ce que j'en sais j'essaie
d'expliquer si c'est pas c'est pas parce
qu'on naît de la volonté politique qui a
des beaux discours politique que
nécessairement les résultats vont être
au rendez vous ça fait des années qu'on
entend si pour le puis vous savez comme
moi que rien contre eux oui vous avez
parlé dans toutes ces trois pour cent je
pense la différence le on s'entend c'est
insignifiant mais l'a par exemple québec
solidaire propose vraiment de bousculer
les habitudes de vie de prendre des
mesures qui sait peut-être contrôle du
ballon mais je comprends qu'ils ont chez
fleurus et 55,6 la liberté individuelle
on reste les bons individuellement de
faire ce qu'on veut qu'elle
met des greffés fermé mais disons aux
gens qu est-ce qui doivent sacrifier
quand québec solidaire il faut baisser
de 50 5 ou même la caquette aqua 37.5
pour ça qu'est ce que vous allez
sacrifiés c'est facile de lancer un
chiffre jamais pu - avec 75% puis ça
serait risible mais juste pour avoir un
chiffre est dans une surenchère pour
vous il n'est pas pour moi c'est de
faire des efforts concrets d'y aller
avec exploiter nos ressources biais de
nos partenaires européens sur la scène
internationale vous savez que juste en
italie de la main mais gnl québec au
saguenay on aurait pu éliminer trois
centrales au charbon en allemagne
présentement on est préoccupés et même
les allemands reconnaissent parce qu'on
est non il ya quatre ans parce que la
cac a reculé mais y'avait pas aussi de
projets économiques mais tous les lieux
accueillant tous dit non parlons de
votre projet troisième rivaux sud
coréens oui c'est pas le même que
monsieur leubou n'ont pas dit où est
charlie
c'est le pont de l'île d'orléans oui
certains disent que ça va le défigurer
alors si les 6000 citoyens de l'île
d'orléans 10 on n'en veut pas de ponts
mais que les milliers de citoyens de
lévis dont on n'en veut pas sur les
horaires vous choisissez qui écouter sur
l'acceptabilité sociale c'est l'ensemble
de la région c'est l'ensemble des gens
qui vont le pays puis ont utilisé mais
je veux juste vous et par rapport à jour
revenir sur la déclaration sur des
figures et les deux rien parce que
c'était monsieur legault utiliser le
même terme de quelques jours juste
rappelé xla monsieur legault propose
essentiellement le même tracé ya quatre
ans quand il a été élu puis à gagny
l'écrasante majorité des entrevues de
monsieur legault il devait y est pas
question et en 2018 vous pouvez
retourner c'est sur les réseaux sociaux
youtube sera du canada pas question des
figures il peut passer ou non billy
police nous non plus qu'il faut qu'ils
passent avoir défiguré moi ce que je
trouve qui défigurent le paysage de
l'île d'orléans présentement c'est les
pylônes électriques et je trouve que
c'est pas mal plus laid qu'un pont un
pont ça pète ne revêt architectural ici
à montréal je pense pas que personne
trouve le nouveau pont champlain affreux
il ya moyen de faire quelque chose de
beau
l'acceptabilité sociale se majorité
c'est quoi vous l'évaluez comment ben
c'est sûr majorité à écouter sur la
rive-nord de mémoire c'est 65 % qui sont
en faveur d' sur la rive-sud c'est 75%
je pense que c'est des chiffres qui sont
assez parlants pas mal plus que le
tramway qui ait jamais eue
d'acceptabilité sociale à québec et où
le gouvernement s'apprête à aller de
l'avant contre la volonté de la
population ou un bon train - je pars au
slogan c'est nous et d'amour et
maintenant merci où nos essences et
quelques secondes sur la fonderie roi
oui pour booster ou là maintenant on
impose la tête de la norme dans
l'approché du site et j'ai visité la
fonderie au il ya quelques semaines et
le gouvernement dit tout et son
contraire la première erreur là dedans
ça a été le manque de transparence je
pense que sur tout le monde est d'accord
que ça va pas de bon sens la deuxième
chose le gouvernement menacé de fermer
l'usiné précieux dit qu'il voulait la
subventionner moi je peux pas pour les
subventions ni pour la fermeture je
pense que ça prend un plan réaliste de
réduction je pense que présentement il y
en a un qui est sur la table puis je
crois que c'est sévère l'eau il faut
aller puis stick le gouvernement à
intervenir ce serait avec l'argent
public pourrait aider par exemple
l'université du québec en
abitibi-témiscamingue avoir une chaire
d'excellence pour justement tenter de
trouver des nouvelles technologies pour
réduire les émissions gaz 1 le pot de
gaz mais de d'arsenic notamment très
bien santé parlons-en temps parlons-en
certains est ce que pour simplifier vous
voulez le système américain est donc
déjà que les moyens est des assurances
puissent aller au privé ce qui ont pas
les moyens là ça se complique par
exemple les modèles qui nous ont inspiré
s'il est beaucoup les modèles européens
momie schalast comme j'allais voir le
modèle suédois eux le modèle anglais le
modèle le modèle allemand l'idée c'est
d'avoir on veut garder l'universalité
vous savez que la loi canadienne sur la
santé nous obligent au canada à ce que
tout le monde puisse avoir accès
gratuitement des soins de santé
maintenant le système actuel est
inefficace ça fait 40 ans qu'on essaie
des réformes et que ça ne fonctionne pas
pour nous le problème c'est le monopole
public il faut instaurer de la
concurrence il faut être instauré une
décentralisation important du système
puis le système qu'on veut au privé mais
je trouve que actuellement un système à
deux vitesses parce que il y en a deux
la descente du privé en santé le fait
pas d'illusion que sauf que justice
juste les gens qui payent au complet
qu'on doit d'y aller nous nous ce qu'on
veut c'est que même le public pourrait
payer dans le privé s'il ne respecte pas
les délais raisonnables ou encore mieux
si les coûts sont moindres dans le privé
donc on aurait un système comme en suède
comme il pourrait avoir deux hôpitaux un
public à côté de l'hôpital privé et les
gens s'y sont pas capables dé soigner
dans le public mais les gens traversent
la rue vont dans le privé et dans
l'assurance des publics l'assurance mais
comme le monde te manque un change de
taux le juge mon assurance paye le taux
belge une commune un accident c'est pas
c'est pas la compagnie spa l'assurance
qui construit le tour qui me fournit le
taux de cgg choix différents
concessionnaires ce serait la même chose
l'assurance reste public mais le la
personne peut aller soit au public soit
au privé comme ça se fait dans la
plupart des pays européens en est un des
rares pays qu'un monopole public où il
n'est pas possible de passer du privé ou
public savait rien du système privé mais
les gens doivent payer comme c'est
complètement ses paris 7ème public et
gratuit c'est même pire que ça on
empêche un médecin par exemple qui peut
juste opéré de trois jours semaine parce
qu'il ya pas de place et peu de salles
pour lui où il ya pas de personnel pour
l'accompagner on l'empêchent de
travailler pendant un an et protéger les
autres jouent mal des ressources on
chante à mon idée heureusement les
ressources compétentes vont aller au
privé mais ce que j'ai à vous dire par
exemple le le médecin qui nous écoutent
le qui fait 2 jours 3 jours puis peut
pas opérer plus parce que ya pas de
place sur votre cote ni les gars décote
mais il pourrait lui prendre deux-trois
jours sont présentement permet pas la
mixité on permet pas un médecin reçoit
100 % privé ou 100% public l'on pourrait
ajouter des soins l'autre exemple c'est
les infirmières vous savez que les
infirmières c'est pas facile on a
entendu parler du temps supplémentaire
obligatoire on sait qui en a plusieurs
qui ont quitté le réseau nous on pense
que s'ils avaient des meilleures
conditions s'il y avait une compétition
en des employeurs je dirais peut-être
suis-je désolé l'horloge va très vite
des garderies c'est un modèle au québec
qui veut être unités ailleurs les femmes
c'est au québec où elles sont le plus
sur le marché du travail grâce à ce que
madame marois a mis sur pied vous vous
dites on ferme tout ça on en voit deux
cents pièces par seconde ips confirme
son dû en garde tout ça mais les 52 min
enfin qui sont sur des listes d'attentes
actuellement le séparant le ils payent
des taxes des impôts comme tout le monde
puis en droit d'avoir des services on va
leur donner 200 pièces par semaine par
enfin parce que eux aussi ont droit
d'avoir des services de garde monsieur
duhaime bonne fin de campagne si le
qatar qui est merci à vous qui a passé
très très vite merci à tous les chefs
merci bonne chance quand pas si on voit
quand vincent combatif convaincu
passionnés c'était intéressant de les
entendre tous attendant un horizon et
spectre merci seller merci mais ça va ma
vie mais je suis fière de partager un
plateau avec vous claudine bourbonnais
va vous présenter le journal moi je vous
retrouve être demain mais sinon le
prochain rendez vous 22 des bons voeux
tous les revoir ensemble
on salue à très bientôt merci à tout le
monde en régime sur le plateau recherche
bon